Hallo Chat Wer ist schon da?
Hallo Hallo Chat Running low on cuties
Was ist da los? Keiner da? Kein Q-Chat am Start
Null Zuschauer, noch nicht mal meine Vorschau wird angezeigt als Zuschauer
Hallo ist so stille, ja irgendwie ist keiner da, allerdings hat es Twitch geschafft diesmal relativ schnell Benachrichtigungen zu verschicken wie es aussieht
Wobei ihr seid bestimmt alle vom Discord da, kann das sein? Weil der Discord ist schneller
Ach hast du fällig gesehen, ok, weil ich weiß, dass die Benachrichtigung im Discord schneller ist
Erstmal alle Messages von gestern deliten bevor sie die Leute sehen
Easy, alle Fragen beantwortet gestern, überhaupt kein Problem
Der online Ridder 2247 Twitch Prime Dankeschön, nice das ging aber schnell
Kaum on schon der erste Sub heute, was ist hier los?
Jetzt kam Twitch Benachrichtigung ok, ja man weiß nicht so genau was Twitch da macht
Heute gucken wir uns nicht mal den YouTube Kanal an, ich weiß auch nicht warum ich den überhaupt offen habe
Wahrscheinlich weil ich irgendeine Seite aufmachen musste bis die Leute da sind
Wir können ja nicht schon anfangen wenn noch keiner da ist, das ist ja irgendwie beknackt
Ja ich hab wieder mal so viel Blödsinn hier drinnen, aber am besten ist immer noch der Sound in Kombination damit
Es gibt ein Update, ja dann zählen wir doch mal ein Update würde ich sagen bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass alles online ist
Ach jetzt ist es so weit, jetzt kommen sie, jetzt kommen sie alle
Wo ist Q-Chat?
Oh Gott Twitch Copy Pastas ey, das ist so schlimm
Ich hab halt auf der Arbeit zu einem gesagt er soll mich nicht debaten
Debated, overrated, outdated
Er hat es nicht verstanden aber ich hab es ihm erklärt dann hat er es kapiert
Aber was das war überhaupt, uns irgendwas zusammen angeguckt
Er hat irgendwas blödes gesagt, ich hab gesagt debate mich nicht, das hat er nicht kapiert
Und dann hab ich eingegeben bei Google debated und dann kam das Gatschi Bass Bild
Guckt mal an, voll fail
Das ist überhaupt nicht, Google lügt
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid auf der Arbeit, die Leute denken eh schon, dass ihr sie nicht mehr alle habt
Und dann sagt ihr zu jemand, jetzt debate mich mal nicht
Und dann fragt er sich, was ist das, das ist ein blödes Twitch Emote, ich zeig's dir
Und dann gebt ihr das da ein und dann kommt Gatschigasm anstatt debated in der Vorschau
Und dann denkt er sich erst recht, der Max dreht komplett durch
Bis ich ihm mal erzählt hab, ne ne eigentlich ist das hier gemeint
Aber Außenstehende können mit Twitch Emotes natürlich nichts anfangen
Man muss aber auch ehrlich sagen, alle Menschen, also quasi alle die noch nicht komplett die Kontrolle über ihr Leben verloren haben
Können wahrscheinlich mit Twitch Emotes nichts anfangen
Also Chaos
Nice Thumbnails, ja sind meine Affinity Designer Skills
Vor allem, warum hab ich hier eigentlich noch mal genau Big Shuck in dem Bild drinne
Hab ich was verpasst, seit wann streamt Max hier, seit
Seit, ich kanns dir genau sagen, seit wann
Wir haben hier den Archiv
Seit
17.09.2017
Überlegt euch mal, ich bin schon wieder zwei Jahre am streben
Und gefühlt ab dem dritten Streben haben die Leute gesagt, ich soll mich mal für Partner bewerben
Und wie lange hab ich gebraucht mich zu bewerben für Partner
Ist noch nicht mal im Archiv überhaupt drinne
Also ich hab ungefähr zwei Jahre gebraucht mich zu bewerben für Partner
Der Sebaro war aber hier nachlässig mit Archiv
Sebaro, was denn da los, der Sebaro im Urlaub
Er ist überhaupt nicht mal aktuell
Nicht aktuell, Stream vom 13.07.
Alex143199999
Quad9
Twitch Prime, Dankeschön
ist könnte man das nicht theoretisch auch automatisch aktualisieren klar aber ich
habe mich da nicht darum gekümmert weil dass sie baro macht das immer auch
ziemlich gut deswegen ich erfreue mich dafür dass ich mich nicht da um alles
kümmern muss so er hat geupdatet würde ich mal sagen kann man das zu machen
ob wir schon studio code drama wieder starten ab gestern selber angefangen dhl abhin
sie scharp einzubinden wollte genau dasselbe machen das ist interessant
irgendwie habe ich die frage überhaupt nicht gesehen gut dass ich mein chat log
habe der muni tab an den nicht der muni der muni
vier des monats geschrieben manchmal bringe ich die leute durcheinander weil
den muni tabaku haben wir auch den habe ich mir auch gemerkt aber ich habe jetzt
jetzt nicht gelesen ihr wisst ja wie das ist wenn man den anfangen den den
anfangen liest von den worter denken wir weiß man schon sofort was sache ist und
dann steht das steht was haben das da
kurz die ganze kreml hier zumachen progas ach das kann ich auflassen weil
es wird mehr öfters gefragt was man für programming sprachen kann langsam wird
es verwirrend es wird echt verwirrend weil den des monat haben wir auch also
dass ich wir hatten ich habe letztens noch mal mein mein mein stream ein
bisschen rein gehört vor letztens wir hatten wir hatten jemanden im stream
der hieß irgendwie litt bums da oder so und ich habe ein paar mal gesagt aus
versehen im stream litt bumser das ist glaube ich keinem aufgefallen
oh das ist immer noch viel immer noch viel zu laut das sound so jetzt sind
genug leute da jetzt kann ich anfangen zu erzählen was wir machen
der moonbjörr der hat es ja schon erzählt hat er schon gespoilert allerdings ist
nur teil von dem was wir machen wollen ich habe überlegt ich brauche mal
irgendwas was man wirklich gescheit von anfangen bis ende und stream
programmieren kann irgendwas was einen gewissen umfang hat was nicht zu viel
umfang hat was mehrere themengebiete abdeckt und was man auch gebrauchen
kann und ich bin auf die idee gekommen wir können ein paket tracker
programmieren allerdings nicht einfach nur den paket tracker sondern einer der
mehrere anbieter unterstützt und man kann sich das am besten vorstellen dass
es kostenpflichtige anbieter da sowas macht und der macht es auch viel viel
besser als wir das jetzt hier selbst programmieren können weil die
unterstützen auch viel mehr anbieter und sowas also wir machen den ganzen nicht
wirklich konkurrenz allerdings für deutschland an sich wird es gar nicht
schlecht man kann sich das ungefähr so vorstellen was verbasteln ich zeige euch
mal das web interface von denen wir bauen das web interface natürlich nicht
nach ich werde bei weitem nicht so viel wert auf das web interface legen
sieht man das irgendwo hier gescheit das sieht kacke aus na gut da erkläre ich
mal eigentlich ich erkläre es mal anstatt anstatt bilder von irgendwelche
anderen produkten zu zeigen also gibt es eine neue app richtig flow 690 gibt eine
neue app und zwar was wir machen ist wie erkläre ich das am besten jetzt also
muss man anders anfangen wenn man bei online shops einkauft
kriegst du ja in der regel immer eine tracking nummer geschickt die sache ist
plus die es gibt keine einheitliche schrittstelle wie man diese tracking
nummern verwalten kann beziehungsweise wie man diese tracking nummer
automatisch tracken kann du kriegst in du kriegst eine benachrichtigung vom shop
vielleicht geschickt du kriegst vielleicht in der bestell übersicht vom
shop angezeigt oder so was ja dann hast du amazon da sieht es wieder ein bisschen
anders aus wie wenn du irgendwie bei einem alternat bestellt so und da habe
ich mir mal überlegt was ist eigentlich das gemeinsame medium das gemeinsame was
man verwenden könnte wo man automatisch sendung verfolgen kann dann bin ich auf
die idee gekommen dass das email postfach eigentlich der beste ort ist
weil wenn man bei allen shops die man bestellt und ich habe eine extra email
die ist nur für online bestellungen da wenn man sich bei allen shops mit der
gleichen die gleiche die gleiche email adresse verwendet wenn man zum
beispiel amazon bei alternat minefactory was ich alles noch gibt wenn du die
gleiche email adresse verwendest dann kriegst du an diese email adressen von
allen shops natürlich total unterschiedlich formatiert kriegst du
bestellbestätigung geschickt ihre bestellung wurde versandt mit dhl und
das ist die tracking nummer mehr oder weniger so sehen diese bestellungs
emails ja immer aus und habe ich überlegt warum macht man nicht einfach
ein programm was regelmäßig in das email postfach reinguckt schaut ob es
dort neue mails findet mit mit tracking nummern also mails die so aussehen als
hätten sie tracking nummern drin danach möglichkeit noch irgendwie anhand der
tracking nummer grob feststellt was könnte das für den anbieter sein und
dann versucht tracking informationen abzurufen automatisch und wohlgemerkt
der der fokus liegt auf automatisch weil software wo ich von hand der tracking
nummer rein pasten muss copy pasten muss die das dann für mich trackt das gibt
es wie santa mehr wobei ich sagen muss so richtig richtig gut die mir gefallen
gibt es auch nicht aber das das kann das kann im endeffekt fast alles fast jede
software die was in der richtung ganze manuell tracking nummer oder einscannen
oder so aber genau passeltrack deswegen habe ich gerade auch gezeigt die machen
das so und ich habe geguckt was ich habe ja damals auch auf twitter gefragt ob
ihr mal einen anbieter kennt und da haben die leute gesagt passeltrack aber ich
bin davor schon selbst auf die idee gekommen mit mit der emailgeschichte und
ich habe das letztes mal mir ganz grob angeguckt wie man das machen könnte und
ich bin jetzt zu dem schluss gekommen dass die beste variante tatsächlich ist
man macht es ein bisschen modulare übrigens ich habe ich habe ich habe ich
vergessen
ähm wo bin ich stehen geblieben genau und das eignet sich auch wunderbar als
projekt für den stream weil kann ich jetzt mal erklären aus was für teilen
das ganze aus ganz aus meiner sicht besteht was wir heute machen ist wir
probieren ein bisschen rum also wir werden das ding heute garantiert
nicht fertig bekommen und noch nicht mal noch nicht mal ansatzweise was haben wo
man sagen kann so wird es am ende aussehen wir werden einfach nur gucken
wie könnte man das ganze umsetzen weil das größte problem bei paketverfolgung
ist nicht das was ich drum herum bauen will das größte problem bei paketverfolgung
ist einmal festzustellen zu welchem anbieter die tracking nummer gehört
und dann die paketverfolgung vom hersteller zu benutzen also vom vom vom
provider vom transportdienstleister zu benutzen den paketstatus abzufragen
und das problem beim abfragen des paketstatus ist dass das wenn du es nicht
richtig machst laufen kaputt geht ich habe schon ein paar ansätze gesehen haben
die leute zum beispiel das hier genommen da haben die leute gesagt ok ich ich
trage ich passt ich gebe hier die die tracking nummer ein das konnte man hier
irgendwie übergeben blablabla tracking nummer und dann paar sich die ausgabe
das ist halt extrem fehleranfällig das heißt das ziel ist sendeverfolgung zu
machen über die offizielle api des jeweiligen anbieters falls es so was
gibt ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen es gibt es nicht bei allen anbietern
amazon hat so was nicht amazon kriegen wir aber relativ easy raus weil bei
amazon in der in der email die man als bestellbestätigung bekommt schon der
link direkt drinnen ist den man benötigt um auf eine ziemlich gut passbare seite
mit sendeverfolgung zu kommen die habe ich vorhin mir auch schon
angeguckt die developer dhl so und damit das ganze funktioniert ich habe mir
überlegt wir brauchen wir brauchen da mehrere teile für und das schöne ist
dass das relativ viele bereiche abdeckt also sprich wir brauchen einmal ich
nenne es mal so was wie einen scanner hat es nichts mit dem scanner zu tun den man
da auf dem drucke hat sondern irgendwas was was sagt man mal abstrakt text
durchsucht das kann beispielsweise sein also suche oder wie nennen wir das denn
suche scanner pattern matching irgendwie so nennen wir das mal das kann sein in
mails das kann sein in text files irgendwo also brauche was abstraktes was
text durchsuchen kann search so genau das ist das eine was wir dafür brauchen
wir brauchen für das ding übrigens so einen guten namen
tracso cute tracso als das ding jetzt
genau tracso door parkett oder das kann kein mensch aussprechen
erst bei den uml diagram zeichnen ja und erstmal kann kann man bord erstellen
er probieren warum was für möglichkeiten gibt wir registrieren uns
mal beim dhl beim dhl developer programm und probieren dann mal ein
bisschen aus überlegen uns generell wie man das ganze aufbauen könnte also als
erstes wie gesagt wir müssen irgendwo text durchscannen und zwar wird durch
scannen den text nach das habe ich mir heute auf der heimfahrt im zug schon
mal überlegt wie man das machen könnte wie durch wie durch scannen den text
nach deck ex für tracking number und das ist leider nicht so ganz aussage
kräftig wenn man wenn man also sagen wir so tracking namen bei manchen bei
manchen anbietern ist nicht sonderlich eindeutig den tracking number
es gibt anbieter die haben einfach eine zehn in eine zehnstellige zahl für den
tracking number aber dhl ist es noch ein bisschen besser aber es gibt anbieter
die haben eine zehnstellige zahl und das sagt bei dhl fängt ja immer alles mit
jd ane nicht unbedingt dhl kann auch mit keine ahnung 014 irgendwas oder so
anfangen also im prinzip dhl tracking number ist
auch nur gesichert dass es eine glaube ich zwölfstellige nummer ist oder so
und eine zwölfstellige oder zehn oder zehn bis zwölfstellige nummer ist halt
wenn man emails durchsucht leider nicht sonderlich aussage kräftig
zehnstellige nummern und selbst wenn sie getrennt sind von von leerzeichen
links und rechts ist nicht gut ja flow 96 der nächste ansatz wäre
einfach alles was irgendwie so aussieht wie eine tracking nummer überprüfen
zu lassen das problem ist aber dass man bei der bei
seinen abfragen relativ schnell ins limit gerät weil die apis an sich die
haben in der in der standardversion bloß 250 anfragen am tag das reicht
normalerweise ohne probleme allerdings wenn ich ganz viele sachen durch probiere
dann ist es nicht so viel
und das nächste ist dass man ja dann letztendlich wenn man emails durchsucht
und emails emails nach pattern abklopft und guckt ob das eine tracking nummer
ist dass man im prinzip ja auch naja was haben wir mal private details aus emails
die eventuell so aussehen wie eine tracking nummer stellt euch mal vor
irgendeiner hat eine kreditkarten nummer drinne stehen und hat sie nicht hat sie
nicht leerzeichen getrennt vielleicht match das auf den regex von vielleicht
match das auf den regex von einer tracking number und du schickst dann
irgendwie die kreditkarten nummer aus versehen zu zum dhl server für für
tracking man ist kein großes problem wahrscheinlich wird der alles gar nicht
mitkriegen aber ich meine man will nicht unbedingt
quasi alles aus seinen emails liegen was irgendwie nach einer tracking nummer
aussieht das heißt das ist gar nicht so einfach wie es aussieht das heißt wir
brauchen noch ein bisschen mehr kriterien woran wir festmachen können
dass es eine email ist wo es um eine tracking nummer geht und das einfachste
was wir machen kann ist zu gucken ob in der email noch der name vom paketdienst
leister vorkommt also wir gucken nach einem regex für tracking nummer und dann
gucken wir ob quasi der name des paketdienst leister zu dem die tracking
nummer gehört sagen wir noch dhl enthält oder so includes dhl und ich
würde sagen wenn ich eine mail finde die auf eine dhl tracking nummer match plus
in der mail noch dhl vorkommt dann kann ich das mal ausprobieren ob das wirklich
eine gültige tracking nummer ist das ist das ist das ist glaube ich fassigen noch ja
paketdienst finde ich auch alles das wunderbar der anbieter heißt halt
einfach so
sind die apis kostenfrei ja die basic version sind kosten nichts bei dhl habe ich
mal angeguckt bei dhl kannst du instanten api zugriff kriegen für 250
abfragen am tag und wenn du dich verifizieren lässt für 1000 abfragen am
tag
email password wieder an dhl übermittel genau so was im endeffekt das willst du
eigentlich sofern wie es irgendwie geht ausschließen was übrigens für mich auch
ein grund ist so was wie parcel track nicht weiter zu verwenden weil ich
müsste ja dass das funktioniert jegliche email dahin weiterleiten von
meinem email account und das will ich nicht
das bricht aber dann wenn generell in der email versand mit hermes und dhl
tritt in der schlimmste fall ist dass die tracking nummer in der mail
zufälligerweise auf hermes und dhl match dann probiert er halt beides aus
und die tracking nummer wird ja wohl nur bei einem anbieter geben und wenn sie
bei beiden anbietern gibt den ersten oder so aber die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
verschwindend gering dass es die gleiche tracking nummer bei den gleichzeitig
aktiv bei zwei unterschiedlichen anbietern gibt
sollte das nicht so ganz passen was wie das match kann man sich ja noch
zusätzliche zusätzliche filter überlegen zum beispiel die email muss den
name enthalten vom vom account besitzer zum beispiel muss er noch plus max
drinne stehen oder so weil in der regel steht ja in der sendeverfolgung immer
sehr geehrter herr wubblors ihre sendung ist auf dem weg versand mit dhl und
sendennummer ist das und das also das heißt man könnte eventuell sagen plus
name ja tru elmo das habe ich mir auch überlegt ob ich es nicht machen soll
allerdings würde ich gerne gucken wie man so was selbst bastelt und was
dazu kommt ich möchte es natürlich auch ganz ich möchte es ja auch für
heimautomatisierung sachen gut integrierbar werden machen
woid denni sagt advanced wäre dann noch wenn man überlegt wie man es macht dass
man kein skammer skennt um als dass man keine spam mails durch durch skennt das
wird sich kaum vermeiden lassen aber wenn es nie mal adresse ist die nur für
nur für shops verwendet und dann sagt man mal bei einem ordentlichen immer
anbieter bist ist das beim mir relativ gering
okay die nächste komponente die wir brauchen ist wir mögen also ja übrigens
was der scanner noch können muss der muss unterstützen dass man nur ab
bestimmte bestimmter zeit skennt also das heißt ich will ja nicht jedes mal alle
mails neu scannen oder nicht jedes mal neu machen
ich will einmal die mails kann dann will ich mir merken was ich für tracking
numbers gefunden habe und das nächste mal wenn ich die mails
gerne scanne ich nur noch alle mails die ab dem zeitpunkt vom letzten mal
scannen drinne waren ja das das sorgt dann auch dafür dass ich nicht die
gleiche sende bestätigung fünf maß gerne was kein problem sein sollte weil
man würde das ganze ja quasi identifizieren anhand der sendungsnummer
und die ist sendungsnummer plus paketdienstleister ist ja dann eine
eindeutige kombination was man dann auch so als als primary key in der
datenbank verwenden könne und das nächste ist ich hätte gerne history für
alle pakete die da durchgegangen sind das sind nämlich so sachen die sind sehr
praktisch und wenn man das ganze eh schon bastelt relativ easy auch einzubauen
also ich hätte gerne history das heißt das war wahrscheinlich mit sq light oder
sowas
die history wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich würde auch einfach ein
textfile reichen ehrlich gesagt brauche history
hätte ich gerne das heißt ja wir schon mehrere sachen abgedeckt mit mehreren
verschiedene gebiete
wie in rücksenden history weil ich einfach wissen will wann ich was
bestellt habe
und ich was bestellt haben und was angekommen ist
verbindest du das auch mit einem sensor im briefkasten guckst ob das wirklich
da ist ne kann ich nicht mal ein sensor im briefkasten kann keine keine label
scan außerdem fallen die pakete auch immer unterschiedlich rein das
funktioniert nicht keine chance oder keine chance ist zu viel gesagt zumindest
zumindest nur sehr advancede chance
genau dann hätte ich natürlich also ja vorher die history mal ist genau nach
der history wir brauchen den eigentlichen tracker da will ich unterstützen also
was mir so vorschwebt ist dhl dhl ist einfach dhl hat eine offizielle api habe
ich geguckt ups ups ist auch einfach haben auch eine offizielle api die habe
ich aber noch nie ausprobiert hermes wird eklig weil hermes hat keine api da
müssen wir irgendwie die webseiten ausgabe pasen oder so das heißt das hat
hohes potential dafür dass es kaputt geht
dann brauchen wir noch ein fallback am ende so dann will ich noch unterstützen dpd die
haben glaube ich auch keine api und was ich unbedingt haben will was offiziell
auch gls und gls krabbel kriege ich nie was kann man sich überlegen und ich
will amazon logistik die haben auch keine api lo und menschen kann ich
schreiben logistik das ist allerdings die haben keine api aber so wie ich das
gesehen habe scheint das relativ einfach zu sein weil wie gesagt der komplette
tracking link den man braucht in der email schon immer mit drinne steht das
heißt ich müsste mir nur den tracking link rausholen aus der mail und komme
dort direkt auf die webseite auf eine gut passbare webseite wo alle tracking
informationen drin stehen und dann hätte ich gerne noch so ein fallback wenn es
mal nicht funktioniert da werde ich irgendwie einen der china tracking
anbieter verwenden es gibt ja jede menge kostenlose tracking anbieter im
internet die eben genau das machen was wir hier nicht machen wollen nämlich die
offiziellen seiten der jeweiligen paketingsleiste anzapfen
allerdings ist es als fallback ganz gut falls man was von uns kaputt geht weil
die haben einfach ein größeres team dahinter um das schneller zu fixen das
heißt wenn wir feststellen dass wir eine mail haben mit sagen wir dpd tracking
nummer und dpd tracking funktioniert gar nicht weil die
irgendwie was geändert haben bei sich genau moonbeard 17 track das habe ich
auch immer verwendet da habe ich sogar schon mal versucht das ganze anzusprechen
die haben zwar keine offizielle api die haben aber eine webseite die man wo man
gut was abgreifen kann die haben es mittlerweile versucht schon
bisschen zu verschleiern dass man das nicht so einfach wenn verwenden kann
wir machen wir machen easy mode kann er jetzt schon sagen also in dem fall der
fälle dass wir wirklich von irgendeinem der anbieter hier die webseite pasen
müssen also wahrscheinlich hier gehe ich mal von aus machen wir easy mode wir
geben uns nicht damit ab dass wir irgendwie ein htp get machen dann regex
machen in der seite oder irgendwie so ein kack nein wir nehmen einen
ferngesteuerten chrome wir nehmen den ferngesteuerten chrome ein headless
ferngesteuerten headless chrome und machen das damit dann hat man nämlich
überhaupt keine probleme mit irgendwelchen eingabefeldern oder sonst
was dann tut man nämlich einfach so als wenn man ein stink normaler benutzer auf
der webseite und klickt das in chrome im hintergrund durch also sie machen hier
keine großartigen pass actions oder sowas da habe ich da habe ich keinen bock
drauf weil das auch immer sehr anfällig ist dafür dass kaputt geht
und den headless chrome fernzusteuern ist mittlerweile ziemlich einfach ja genau
heck so das ding lockt sich per ein map ein oder wir können ein map machen ein
map für die leute die pop 3 haben oder pop 3 machen dann werden wir es
allerdings so machen dass die pop 3 messages eben nicht gelöscht werden
sondern nur abgerufen werden wieso machst du das nicht mit einem rpa
programm ich weiß doch nicht was ein rpa programm ist also was ist ein rpa
programm kann ich kann ich alle abkürzeln können ja richtig dass man das war mein
pappertier gibt es ja mittlerweile auch für bindings für andere programmiersprachen als
was ist die offizie was ist das offizielle binding go desktop automatisierung
robotic process automation aja ist klar das muss man natürlich wissen das was
es heißt
wir machen es ja zum teil so wir werden sagen wir werden chrome fernsteuern
wenn wir das brauchen am besten nehmen natürlich die offizielle ab das ist
immer noch das beste weil es einfach so wenn man die offizielle dhl und ups api
nimmt geht halt nichts kaputt wenn man irgendwelche webseiten passt geht halt
alle furz lang was kaputt und deswegen pasen wir auch keine webseiten sondern
für den fall der fälle dass keine api gibt steuern wir den chrome fern und das
geht natürlich aber auch in die hose wenn sich die webseite grundlegend ändert
flo 96 wer nutzt bitte noch pop 3 keine ahnung gibt aber bestimmt immer noch
leute pop 3 verwenden so und die nächste komponent ist natürlich web interface
plus ich hätte gerne home assistant integration das wird relativ einfach
über mqtt oder sowas dann laufen da kann sich ja chat jetzt wieder freuen
wenn ich mqtt gesagt habe mit blazer ich weiß nicht ob wir das mit blazer
machen müssen wir mal gucken
genau und die letzte komponente der ganzen geschichte eine mobile app
brauchen wir nicht wir haben wir haben eine web interface das ist mobile app
genug und es können ja mittlerweile alle
betriebssysteme auch halbwegs anständig progressive web apps außer ios außer
ios so und die letzte komponente ist notification also sprich dass das ding
einem email schicken kann oder dass das ding eine discordnachricht schicken kann
oder so das machen wir dann aber als letztes das ist eigentlich die
unwichtigste die unwichtigste sache da dran single page application wahrscheinlich
ja wahrscheinlich ich werde ihr wisst ja ich bin nicht der allergrößte web
web anwendung hexa ich werde das machen was ich kenne was ich jetzt in letzter
zeit schon bewertet für ein paar sachen die ich gemacht habe das ist wie gs im
frontend und asp.net core im backend wir können uns auch überlegen ob wir
irgendeine push notification einbauen ja wenn man einen passenden passenden
anbieter haben ist kein ding können wir machen aber das ist das unwichtigste
erstmal dran und das das das also das ist wahrscheinlich das einfachste also
ne nicht das einfachste dass das das am klarsten wie es funktioniert und ist erst wichtig wenn
der andere kram funktioniert so und ich würde sagen wir gucken uns jetzt erst
mal an was für anbieter irgendwelche apis haben weil ich habe vorhin noch
mal kurz geguckt und wir probieren mal testweise die dhl api aus glücklicherweise
haben wir viele leute von euch gestern ein paar test tracking numbers geschickt
ein dotnet cross service irgendwie sowas haben wir mal gucken also das ganze mit
dotnet core anwendung wir verabschieden uns mal vom normalen dotnet framework
ja aber jetzt gucken wir mal was es für anbieter gibt also ich weiß dass das ist
von dhl was gibt er findet zwar immer noch die seite die auch irgendwie geht
aber ich war da vorhin schon mal drauf die richtige seite hat immer noch einen
chat gepostet ist eigentlich das hier ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung warum es
da unterschiedliche unterschiedliche sachen gibt also ich weiß nicht warum es
entwickler dhl de gibt und warum es die hl developer portal gibt keine ahnung
aber die haben zumindest was ist ein spa eine spa das ist eine single page
application also im prinzip eine webseite die nur aus einer seite besteht
die die logik auf dem client macht und ich hoffe so aber so grob gesagt die
webseite sieht wirklich nach 1995 aus so ups hat auch eine api das habe ich
vorhin auch schon nachgeguckt da habe ich aber noch überhaupt nicht
geschaut wie man das ganze benutzen kann ist aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht
sondern nicht kompliziert und wir müssen mal gucken
wo ist die tracking api geht aber wahrscheinlich auch immer wieder
bescheuert wenn es keine kein tracking gebe soll das nächste ist die keine api
am selbe hermes hermes sagt aber eh
hermes hat sowas nicht
hermes müssen wir die webseite passen
hermes monka es dpd hat glaube ich auch keine public api doch die haben vielleicht
was ok
dpd hat vielleicht was und amazon logistics hat garantiert nichts das weiß
ich also das heißt wenn man sich das hier
angucken die haben eine api die haben eine und die haben eine das ist schon
mal eine ziemlich gute ausbeute weil ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch ist bei mir
ist es so die meisten pakete kommen mit dhl ups oder aber mit dpd hermes ist
relativ selten und in letzter zeit ziemlich häufig mit amazon logistics
machst du die app native oder im web halbe halbe also eine reine webapp geht
natürlich nicht ich meine wir müssen backend geschichten machen und
hintergrund sachen laufen lassen das ding wird ein web frontend kriegen dass
man sich angucken kann ja genau und ich würde sagen das auszuprobieren
registrieren wir uns mal nutz zu lara well und ähnliches ich habe mal was in
lara well gemacht vor jahren nämlich eine das dead seite mit
unterschiedlichen profilen für die spieler auf meinem damaligen
battlefieldserver aber seitdem habe ich mit lara well nichts mal gemacht ich
habe es damals auch nur mit lara well pfp gemacht weil eben jeder 0815
hosting anbieter pfp unterstützt
das war so richtig damit das war wenn ich überlege so richtig 0815 zeug mit
pfp und mysql es war eigentlich ganz gut ich weiß ich ob es jemand gibt der auf
dem server gespielt hat damals das war glaube ich in den battlefield
battlefield 4 server war das als bf oder bf 3 bf 4 bf 3 habe ich auf
xbox gespielt zum größten teil das war glaube ich in bf 4 server und da
hattest du quasi so eine besten liste nach kills nach zeit auf dem server und
du konntest auf den spieler klicken dann hat sie dann quasi so ein mini
eigenes profil wurde dann gesehen hast wie geil du abgegangen bist und geil
geout hast auf dem server war eigentlich ganz nice das war das war ein
lara well pfp gemacht mit mysql dabei
so leute was meint ihr was bei dhl die bessere seite ist das da die sieht
moderner aus die internationale seite oder das dhl developer portal was eine
deutsche seite ist allerdings auf englisch
aber was ist mit xml xml also wenn das hier geht das sieht auch guckt euch das
mal da oben an das ist xml monka xml
sie sieht wirklich schon aus wie xml
monka xml monka xml monka xml
stack auf a floor ist da und das glaube ich net
wow
sachen gibts stack auf a floor ist da und das habe ich ja noch nie gesehen
das habe ich ja noch nie gesehen
und und wie können die das jetzt beheben
das ist doch eigentlich gar nicht möglich dass der fehler behoben wird
weil wenn die nicht weiter wissen müssen sie auf stack auf a floor fragen
da beißt sich so ein bisschen henne eye problem wenn stack auf a floor down ist
können die jungs von stack auf a floor nicht auf stack auf a floor fragen wenn man stack
auf a floor wieder zum laufen bekommt
oh ich sehe schwarz ich sehe echt schwarz dafür also ich glaube das vorbei
ja ich weiß auch nicht was ich jetzt machen soll wir probieren jetzt die dhl api aus
also wo kann man sich registrieren log register ok ok leute fake account zeit
first name
lull die kommen wir machen wir machen das wir machen das realistisch ich
wollte gerade so best of best of twitch namen best of twitch namen machen also
nachname noscope meister
wubbler wubbler noscope meister email adresse oh jetzt wird schwierig
wir brauchen wir brauchen eine fake email adresse ten minute mail ok habe ich noch
nie ausprobiert verwende meistens ich verwende meistens das hier
verwende meistens das da ich habe keine ahnung wer das betreibt hier rolf stadthaus
das ist total easy einfach irgendwas angeben und gut ist
ten minute mail free anonymos temporäri mail and uren.com ok interesting ist das
jetzt so gemacht dass das kann ich dann selbst wenn ich das mal angenommen ich
würde jetzt das fenster zumachen kann ich dann selbst noch auf die email
zugreifen oder ist das quasi hier so session gebunden also das heißt selbst
ihr im stream könntet jetzt nicht darauf zugreifen oder was das ist ja was
ist ja auch im prinzip egal ok email adresse das da username 360 master
kompanie stremsor gmbh in deutschland
i have read and accept terms of use ja und robot bin ich auch nicht
traffic lights ich liebe ja captures das da das da das da das da obweist
in das traffic lights ich sehe keine traffic lights sonst mehr verify
hey hat funktioniert stimmt immer adresse refreshen ja ok send
o b o b o b o b o b o b o b o b o b o o dhl high speed ist schon mal richtig
schnell hier welkom da ist es ja also mein login ist 360 master ok
Passwort, dann nehme ich jetzt wirklich mal ein Passwort, was ihr nicht erraten könnt
Im Endeffekt ist es wurscht ich verwende das für nichts anderes mehr safe
Okay, sehr schön. Wow!
Okay, ähm, meinetwegen, ähm, was?
Kann ich mal mein eigenes Passwort mehr schreiben?
Ha! Funktioniert! Okay, der Wubbler No-Scorp Meister 360 Master ist angemeldet.
Sehr gut.
Sehr schön. Add App.
Okay, App Name.
Cute Chat.
Description brauchen wir nicht. Und als API wollen wir haben, habe ich mir nämlich
vorher schon durchgelesen, man muss Starter auswählen.
Shipment Tracking, Starter. Weil wenn man Starter auswählt,
Description, ah ja ja, genau. Wenn man Starter auswählt, muss man sich
nicht verifizieren lassen, weil ich kann mich ja auch schlecht mit diesem
Account verifizieren lassen. Es sei denn, ich würde wirklich Wubbler
No-Scorp Meister heißen.
Ah, ich würde mal sagen, easy, Namensänderungen raus.
Die Unified API ist noch Beta. Ja, aber sie ist Unified.
Was auch immer das heißt. Wahrscheinlich, dass alle möglichen DHL-Sprösslinge
Abwandlung unterstützt werden.
Okay, Cute Chat ist approved. Endlich.
Okay. API Documentation, Documentation, API.
Shipment Tracking Unified. Also, schauen wir mal, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Los, Scope. Also, was wird unterstützt? DHL-E-Commerce, DHL-Express, DHL-Fright,
DHL-Global Forwarding, DHL-Parcel Germany, Netherlands, Poland, DHL-Supply Chain.
Was nicht unterstützt wird, ist irgendwelche Business-to-Business-Systeme.
Mirikari, ja, natürlich. Das werden wir bei Hermes auch machen müssen,
sowas in der Richtung. Post-Letter-Tracking. Post ist Part of DHL-Passenger.
Damit kann ich leben, wenn wir keine Waren-Sendungen tracken können oder sowas.
Ich wusste gar nicht, wie das überhaupt geht. Okay, was kriegen wir?
Shipment-Locations, Delivery-Time, History, Delays, Proof of Delivery.
Ja, gut, das brauche ich nicht. Shipment, Timestamp, Address.
Das mit der Adresse geht übrigens nicht. Das mit der Adresse geht nur, wenn man sich,
wenn man quasi weiß, wer der Typ ist, der es kriegt. Also, nur wenn ich derjenige bin,
der das quasi losgeschickt hat. Also, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach,
wenn ich eine Tracking-Nummer habe, mir anzeigen lassen, was der für eine Adresse hat.
Wenn ja auch ein bisschen fail, ne? Gewicht, Abmaße.
Okay, Using-RP-Example-Use-Cases, bla, bla, bla, bla. Check-If-DP, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
User-Guide. Example-Request. Leicht doch schon. Bam. Curl. Easy. Curl.
Auf geht's. Würde ich mal sagen, machen wir mal eine Testabfrage gegen die DHL-RP.
Gucken wir mal, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Vielleicht sollte ich noch Paste-Key-Here auch meinen Key reinpasten,
anstatt das einfach so zu Copy-Pasten. Consumer-Key, da. Bam. Key liegt.
Da ist es. Pock. Okay, mal ordentlich formatieren.
Okay, das ist anscheinend der Test-Tracking-Number von denen.
Also, wie ist das Ganze denn so aufgebaut? Shipments, all die, dann steht drunter Service.
Also sprich, mit was es genau versandt wurde, wobei mir das persönlich egal ist.
Weil, wenn ich was, wenn ich ein Paket bekomme, interessiert mich, wo das ist,
nicht ob, mit was es der Typ versandt hat, ja.
Also, Origin ist, wo das Paket herkommt. Das kommt aus China.
Aus China, wie das manche Leute sagen. Das Paket kommt aus China.
Destination ist Japan. Status ist...
Ah, okay, Status ist wahrscheinlich das, was gerade aktuell ist.
Shipment-Information received. Und dann sieht man auch irgendwie sowas wie,
was für anderen Teile da Bestandteil von dem Tracking sind oder so, ich glaube.
Also, nicht so interessant. Events dürfte, glaube ich, interessanter sein.
Weil jetzt geht's irgendwie nach, irgendwie nach Italien. Ein bisschen, bisschen übersichtlich.
Okay, ich nehme mal eine Tracking-Nummer, die funktioniert.
Weil, es hat mir ja jemand, also man sieht hier keine, keine, keine Adresse.
Also, man sieht jetzt nicht, wo derjenige wohnt. Es hat mir, es haben mir ja Leute
quasi gestern netterweise Tracking, Tracking-Number zur Verfügung gestellt.
Ich glaube, der Eichler war es, der mir die Tracking-Number hier zur Verfügung gestellt hat.
Ich will jetzt, ich will jetzt mal nichts leaken vom Eichler.
Guck mir das vorher mal an, ob das, no shipments found, okay.
Dann habe ich mich vielleicht vercopy-pasted. Dann habe ich mich vielleicht vercopy-pasted,
weil ich habe noch eine gekriegt, nehme ich die hier. Ah, okay.
Ja, da stehen keine Adressen drin, sage ich doch. Wäre ja auch fail.
Da könnte man ja alles über diejenigen rauskriegen, wenn du mal eine Paket-Nummer gesehen hast.
Okay, also das ist jetzt eine realistische, eine echte Tracking-Nummer vom Eichler.
Ich glaube, der Eichler war das. Nettes I3 Setup. Ja, damit habe ich eine Weile dran,
eine Weile dran geschraubt. Die erste Nummer war deine von DPD.
Dann habe ich, dann habe ich mich vertan, weil ich habe mir die unter DHL aufgeschrieben.
Schreibe ich noch mal hin, dass das, dass die erste Nummer, dass das DPD ist.
Okay, also was sehen wir denn hier? Das ist in Deutschland. Origin ist Deutschland.
Das ist okay. Destination ist Deutschland, ist auch okay. Status, timestamp, timestamp,
Alter, timestamp. Hier, status code delivered. Das ist das, was es aktuell ist.
Also sprich, die Sendung ist beim Eichler daheim angekommen. Ich glaube,
das war der Eichler, der das, der das gestern geschickt hat. Der hatte so einen Namen,
den kann ich mir auch immer gut merken, der Eichler.
Es ist schon mal schön, dass es kein komischer XML Dialekt ist.
Okay, wir wissen auch, er hat sich was für 1,34 Kilo bestellt. Ein Stück. Events.
Events gehen von oben nach unten, würde ich sagen. Transit.
Transit. Ach, das sind die unterschiedlichen,
die unterschiedlichen Dinge. Also, was interessiert ist, der status code
delivered, der timestamp und der timestamp ist nicht so ganz in der richtigen Reihenfolge,
oder? Geht es von unten nach oben oder von oben nach unten? Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Warum ist pre-transit for transit? Timestamp 16. Doch, das geht von unten nach oben.
Aber das ergibt keinen Sinn. Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Warum ist das Paket schon unterwegs, wenn es der nächste Schritt in pre-transit ist?
Das ist, das ist DHL Logiker. Willkommen in der Business Logic von DHL.
Irgendwie ergibt es keinen Sinn. Aber macht ja nichts. Was uns interessiert ist,
hauptsächlich das hier, nämlich was der aktuelle, nämlich das hier interessiert uns eigentlich.
Der aktuelle Status juckt uns und der aktuelle Status ist ausgeliefert. Die Events sind dann
ganz nett, aber so wirklich interessant ist doch eigentlich nur der aktuelle Status. Weil
ich frage, ich frage das ja eh, keine Ahnung, paar mal, paar mal am Tag ab.
Also, was? Writgoy? Freut man das so aus? Also ich finde es irgendwie unlogisch,
dass als erstes transit kommt und danach pre-transit.
Okay, ich würde sagen, wir probieren jetzt mal einfach, die DHL API abzufragen. Mit
einem kleinen, mit einem bisschen C-Sharp. Also, ich habe mir das Ganze so vorgestellt.
Wir werden das streammäßig ungefähr in der Reihenfolge machen. Wir werden das streammäßig
ungefähr, kannst du auch Fridge sagen? Okay, Fridge finde ich deutlich einfacher.
Fridge Prime, nice, Dankeschön. Jetzt könnte ich auch mal automatisch einspielen.
Ich finde, ich finde ja, wie sie das vorliest, klingt richtig gut, oder? Subscriber! Subscriber!
Das war es falsch. Also ich habe mir das streammäßig vorgestellt, das in folgender Reihenfolge
zu machen. Also, als erstes basteln wir, ähm, für unser Backend, quasi, die, die, die,
die, die, die, nennen wir es mal, nennen wir es mal, ähm, Infra, ne, Infrastruktur ist
doof. So die unterste Ebene würde ich als erstes in dem Fall mal basteln. Nämlich,
dass ich ne, ne, ne, ne fertige C-Shop-Klasse hab, oder wie auch immer, was ich genau mache,
mit der ich alle Anbieter ansteuern kann. Das ist erstmal das Wichtigste. Wenn ich das
gemacht hab, also nennen wir es, nennen wir es mal hier, Low-Level-Tracking-RPs. Das
ist das erste, was wir machen. Für DHL, UPS und DPD. Resten müssen wir da mal gucken.
So, und den Fallback machen wir vielleicht auch noch. Das ist das erste, was wir machen.
Ähm, oh, wir haben noch ne Twitch Prime Sub, Silent Sync. Hast du nicht letztens schon
mal gesubbt? Geht eigentlich gar nicht, aber der Name kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Kommt das auf GitHub? Joa, wenn's funktioniert. Wie unregelmäßig es ist, bist du's auf GitHub
pushen? Ja, unregelmäßig halt. Nice, äh, Silent Sync.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice. Hab ich euch übrigens schon erklärt?
Als falls ihr einen Amazon Account habt und über Amazon Prime verfügt, könnt ihr euren
Amazon Account kostenlos mit eurem Twitch Account verknüpfen und ihr bekommt dann Twitch Prime. Das bringt euch monatlich
kostenloses Prime Loot und ihr könnt einmal im Monat einen Streamer eurer Wahl mit einem Tier-1-Sub unterstützen und das ganze
kostet euch 0, nix.
Allerdings kriegt der jeweilige Streamer einen ganz normalen Share von Twitch ab.
Musst du das eigentlich sagen, jetzt wo du Partner bist? Ne, ich muss das nicht sagen, aber wenn ich schon Partner bin,
dann erzähle ich es auch ab und zu mal, weil wozu bin ich Partner, wenn ich dann schon gar nichts davon habe. Da hätte mich auch, das hätte ich mir auch das Bewerben sparen können.
Wenigstens kann ich hier sagen, ey, ich wurde ja fast schon dazu gedrängt Partner zu werden.
Ne? Von mir, von mir, es war ja nicht so, dass ich quasi, ich bin zwei Jahre zu spät, dass ich irgendwie gesagt hätte, alter Max hier, Partner, Money abgreifen.
Max will kein Twitch-Money, doch, doch, ich nehme alles Twitch-Money, was es gibt.
Wenn du Twitch-Money ausgeben willst, Mr. Ami, eine super Variante ist, in dem du einfach dem Chat ein paar Subs giftest.
Da bekommen nämlich Leute Subs, die es vielleicht gerne hätten und sich nicht leisten können und du kannst mir dann Twitch-Money geben und alle anderen haben auch noch was von.
Wann kommen Sub-Emotes? Als erstes kommt erstmal ein ordentliches Sub-Batch und nicht diese hässliche Sterne, die da immer standardmäßig drin ist.
Und Sub-Emotes, ich hab, ich hab einen übelst hässlichen Keks gemalt, also ich hab den nicht gemalt, der Eax hat den gemalt, aber den, ne, werden wir nicht als Emote üben,
weil der sieht, der sieht so kacke aus, das nehmen wir nicht. Ich muss mir irgendwas ausdenken, ich hab noch überhaupt keine Ahnung, keine gute Idee für, für Emotes.
Wir haben übrigens im Discord, wir haben im Discord einen Channel, wenn jemand von euch eine richtig gute Idee hat, was man für einen Emote machen könnte, oder was für Emotes,
man machen könnte, schreibt's bitte ins Discord. Im Discord gibt's einen Channel, irgendwie sowas wie Emote-Vorschläge, da kann man posten, was für Emotes es schon gibt,
welche ihr gerne hättet, im Channel mit BellaTwitchTV und FFZ. Oder wenn ihr Vorschläge habt, was wir selbst für Emotes machen können, für den Channel, schreibt's da rein, weil ich bin unglaublich unkreativ.
Äh, ich hab mir jetzt übrigens Wupp als Prefix für Emotes gesichert. Kann man aber ändern.
Was und verify dich mal noch bei Brave? Was ist Brave? Ich kenn bloß einen Brave Browser.
Was ist Brave?
Wupp-S, genau, Wupps.
Wuppler-S. Warum soll ich mich bei Brave verifizieren? Hä, wozu?
Was hat man davon, wenn man sich bei Brave verifiziert? Wegen Brave-Krypto-Money. Ach so, jetzt weiß ich, was man sagt, Alter.
Ja, da wär ich jetzt gar nicht drauf gekommen. Oh, wir haben noch einen Twitch Prime-Sub.
Boah, es kann sein, dass ich das übelst falsch ausspreche. Face-Aid? Oder Fesk? Fesk-Aid?
Auf jeden Falle, danke für den Twitch Prime-Sub, das ist sehr nice.
Muss immer ein bisschen variieren.
Dann krieg ich Krypto-Money, wenn ich mich da verifiziere. Ah ja, kannst du deine Webseite bitte mal bei Links auflisten?
Welche Webseite?
Meinst du meinen YouTube-Channel? Der ist doch schon drinnen. Das Archiv, oder was meinst du?
Ach, das Archiv. Ja, kann ich machen. Kann ich machen. Mach ich mal, warte mal, geht doch ganz einfach hier, bearbeiten und jetzt Archiv.
Müsste gleich drinne stehen, Moment. Archiv. Wublords.tv.
So, Speichern. Ja, sollte drinne stehen. Der Profil-Seite.
Wir machen auf der Arbeit manche Dinge mit den Azubis nach. Boah, was ist, das ist sehr nice. Was macht ihr denn da sonst z.B.?
Was für Azubis? Anwendungsentwicklung, System-Integration, was macht ihr denn da sonst z.B.?
Was für Azubis? Anwendungsentwicklung, System-Integration, krasse DevOps-Azubis, was es ja nicht gibt.
Das Archiv, genau. NeroBion. Noch mehr Twitch Prime Subs. Dankeschön, nice. Nein, falscher. Falsches Emote.
Nice. Wir flashen jetzt auch mal die geile Steckerleiste von Kogeek. Ernsthaft, das ist ja cool. So ist das immer, Leute.
Jetzt wird auch schon China Zeug geflashed zum Üben. Das ist auch eine gute Sache, da kann man sich ein bisschen vertraut machen mit einem Raspberry Pi, kann man Linux drauf installieren, kann man sich die ganze Sache mal auf GitHub angucken.
Das ist tatsächlich ein richtig cooles Projekt für Azubis, denke ich. Vor allem für Leute, die damit noch nichts gemacht haben, können das sie trotzdem schaffen. Das finde ich, das ist nice. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Also, nochmal schnell, was ich sagen wollte. Also, in der Reihenfolge, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe, wir machen jetzt erstmal die ganzen Low-Level-APs. Basteln wir jetzt erstmal.
Danach basteln wir den Mail-Scanner. Und wenn das funktioniert, machen wir dann das Web-Interface. So, in der Reihenfolge, habe ich mir gedacht, machen wir das Ganze.
Und danach machen wir dann erst, das müssen wir zeitgleich machen, dazu kommt dann, dass wir die History-Datenbank machen mit eigentlichem Tracking dabei.
So, in der Reihenfolge werden wir das machen. Also, wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal an, wie man die DHL-AP ordentlich anspricht. Genau, also machen wir Visual Studio auf 19. Ich habe ja mittlerweile drei Visual Studios installiert.
Die Brifio-Variante für Blazer und.NET Core 3, Studio 19 und 17 noch, weil das Projekt ein bisschen älter ist. Create New Project.
Wenn man viel speichert, das ist ein gutes Stichwort. Ich muss die VMs von gestern noch löschen. Kann ich aber nachher machen. Okay, also, Projekt. Wir machen mal eine Konsolen-Anwendung zum Ausprobieren. Schade hier nichts.
Konsolen-App 12, bester Name. DHL-Test, nennen wir das Ganze mal. DHL-Test. So, DHL-Test. Create.
Hat 19 viele Vorteile gegenüber 17. Es sind ein paar coole Sachen in 19 dabei. Zum Beispiel für Teams die ganze Live-Share-Geschichte ist wirklich sehr nice. Das Sündags-Highlighting ist ein bisschen schöner in 19.
Der Test-Runner ist viel besser geworden, finde ich. Aber ich meine, Test ist ja eher massiv overrated, she baited. Wer braucht noch Tests? Ansonsten fällt mir jetzt aus dem Stegreif gar nicht allzu viel ein.
Vielleicht fallen euch noch Vorteile ein. Also aus dem Kopf raus fällt mir jetzt nicht allzu viel ein. Was sonst noch neuer wäre, besser wäre.
Okay, also, wir kopieren uns jetzt mal den Curl-Aufruf hier raus. Wir kopieren uns jetzt mal den Curl-Aufruf hier raus und bauen das nach und parsen das Ganze dann am Endeffekt.
Parsen das Chasen, was dabei rauskommt. Jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal überlegen, wie wir das Ganze aufbauen wollen. Warum rückt der da eigentlich immer was ein? Crap. Crap, Alter.
Jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal überlegen, wie wir das Ganze aufbauen wollen, weil wir wollen ja für jede Low-Level-RP, dass die immer so ähnlich aussieht. Also würde ich sagen, wir machen erstmal ein Interface.
Erstmal ein Interface, wie sowas wie Eye, keine Ahnung, Eye Tracker oder so. Welche Version von Visual Studio benutzt du und wie viel kostet die?
Na, das ist gerade 19. Das ist 17. Also ich hab 17, 19, 19 Preview installiert und das kostet nichts. Die Community-Variante ist kostenlos. Das einzige, was du machen musst, ist nach 30 oder 60 Tagen, musst du dich mit einem Microsoft-Account registrieren oder mit einem bestehenden Microsoft-Account verknüpfen.
Mehr musst du nicht machen. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich weiß gar nicht, was mittlerweile noch die großen Vorzüge sind von einer bezahlten Visual Studio-Version.
Früher war das, diese ganze Microsoft, wie hieß das, Teamsafe oder Codesafe oder Team Foundation, wie hieß das, was kein Mensch verwendet hat so richtig, ging nur richtig gut in der Pro-Variante.
Ansonsten, ein paar statische Code-Analysen gehen, glaube ich, nur richtig in Pro. Team Foundation, genau.
Ansonsten, ich glaube für sowas hier hält sich das echt in Grenzen. Wo ist eigentlich der Sebaro? Stimmt, wo ist der Sebaro?
Wir müssen den Sebaro beschwören.
Das geht nur so.
Aber es hat nichts gebracht.
Achtung Leute, wartet mal.
Moment, gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Ops, falsche Sprachausgabe.
Mein Meme-Bot ist gecrashed.
Das ist gecrashed, als ich auf die Reap-Stimme umgestellt habe.
Warum das denn?
Monka Crash bräuchten wir als E-Mode, wobei Monka Crash haben wir ja schon.
Wir haben ja Dings hier, wir haben ja Monka Smoke, das ist ja quasi für sowas schon nie gemacht.
Warum ist das jetzt gecrashed?
Das muss ich noch mal ausprobieren.
Hinzufügen, Reap-E-Mode, Sebaro.
Hört sich doch gut an. So wie ich den Sebaro kenne, ist das wahrscheinlich schon was Japanisches.
Das hätte ich nicht reinkopieren sollen.
Das ist richtig Five Head, Big Brain.
Alles klar, muss Koss, ja.
Du musst nicht Koss, du musst wahrscheinlich Koss gerade.
Wenn ich los muss, ist es meistens nicht, weil ich Koss muss, sondern weil ich Koss muss.
Okay, weiter im Text, ich habe mich voll abgelenkt. Wir haben es jetzt geschafft, dass wir Interface eingegeben haben und noch Hello World dastehen haben, ganz toll.
Also, wir müssen uns überlegen, wie wir die ganzen API-Tracker machen.
Das einfachste ist, dass wir eine Interface machen. Wir müssen uns mal überlegen, ob wir eine Base Class machen oder ob wir eine Interface machen. Wahrscheinlich machen wir eine Interface, das ist einfach schöner.
Also moderne Base Classes nimmt man, wenn man Logik scheren will, aber relativ selten mittlerweile.
Interface ist überwiegend eindeutig.
Willst du nicht lieber eine Factory machen? Ja klar, wenn ich Java wäre, würde ich jetzt erstmal den Factory Manager anwerfen.
Okay, und das Interface für einen Tracker, der Name ist doof, da muss ich mir etwas anderes einfallen lassen. Vielleicht fällt euch ja ein gescheiter Name dafür.
Tracker ist dumm, der trackt ja nichts. Das ist ein... Was ist denn das?
Für was steht das i? Das ist so Convention, dass man Interfaces anfängt.
Es ist kein Tracker, es ist ein...
Tracking...
API...
Get Drexor, ja genau. Wir lassen es jetzt erstmal so.
Alles...
Tracking Proxy, API Request, Verfolger, oder Verfolger ist, Subscriber ist am Start.
Der Hadi, Stufe 1, Dankeschön, nice.
Big Brain Abos am Start.
UML-Klassendiagramm, ja ganz genau. Wie gesagt, als nächstes brauchen wir noch unser agiles Kanban-Board. Nur so kann das funktionieren.
Also, wir brauchen... Wir brauchen, wir möchten da eine Methode haben, die sich nennt, irgendwie...
Ich bin gerade echt unkreativ. Tracking Info, oder irgendwie so.
Receive Tracking Info.
Irgendwie so.
Ok, und jetzt müssen wir uns überlegen, wie verpacken wir die Infos, die wir da von DHL zurückkriegen, beziehungsweise...
Wie verpacken wir überhaupt so eine Tracking History, ist es ja im Endeffekt.
Also, da brauchen wir eine extra Klasse für. Die nennen wir jetzt mal irgendwie...
History, Events, oder, oder, oder.
Was heißt denn?
Könnte man das jetzt gescheit nennen?
Order? Order ergibt auch keinen Sinn.
Was heißt denn Sendung auf Englisch?
Glass Verlaufsliste, ja.
Shipment, Shipment, genau.
Shipment History, das klingt auch schon ein bisschen schöner.
Shipment Tracker ist das jetzt auch.
Ah, Receive...
Receive reicht, wenn das Ding heißt iShipmentTracker. Was will ich da sonst receive, wenn ich den, die, die...
History, ja. So ist das. Wieder schon mal schöner.
So, ähm...
Und dann...
Ja, und da müssen wir das jetzt irgendwie reinpacken. Also, was für Infos brauchen wir da eigentlich?
Wir brauchen sowas wie nen, sowas wie nen Status.
So, Status, brauchen wir nen E-Namen für.
Wir legen das jetzt mal alles, ich, ich mach das jetzt mal so komplett brain-dump-mäßig, so was mir so einfällt.
Status von der Sendung ist, ähm, unter, also im Prinzip ist das unterwegs, in Zustellung und angekommen, oder?
Wie nennt DHL den ganzen Kram noch mal hier?
Transit, Delivered, Pre-Transit, Pre-Transit interessiert uns nicht.
Also, Transit interessiert uns, Delivered und, ähm...
Verloren, ja gut, wir müssen gucken, wie die Sachen bei DHL heißen.
In Auftrag gegeben, im Paketzentrum angekommen, in Zustellung...
Ja, mir reichen, ganz ehrlich, für so nen Sendungs-Tracker, wo ich dann auch ein bisschen in meine Heimautomatisierung gucken kann, reichen mir erstmal drei verschiedene Status-Sachen aus.
Jetzt zum Auslesen. Man kann das ja immer noch erweitern, man darf ja nicht vergessen, das muss ja auch allgemeingültig sein.
Also sprich, so diese drei Sachen wie unterwegs, ähm, ausgeliefert und in Zustellung, die sind ja auch universal, die funktionieren ja auch bei allem.
Ich muss mal kurz in mich gehen, wie man das nennen könnte.
Wie könnte man nennen, dass das in Zustellung ist?
Ah, wir könnten das so nennen.
So, das klingt auch ein bisschen holprig, oder?
Dann...
Na, ich hätte gern ein Wort, ich hätte gern ein Wort, was das beschreibt.
Das ist ja auch nichts, was wir im Web-Interface so anzeigen müssen, das ist was, was wir intern als Status verwenden können, wo wir wissen, dass das bedeutet, auf dem Weg heim.
Na, abgeschlossen ist klar, dann ist abgeschlossen, dann heißt das Ding ist da.
Nein, ich will nicht, ich brauch kein Wort für, es ist on the way, ich brauch ein Wort für, es ist im Auto und wird zugestellt.
Nicht Transit bedeutet ja, es wird zu mir transportiert und an dem Tag, wo es zugestellt wird, ist es halt im Auto, 012, 012 kann ich empfehlen.
In delivery.
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie gefällt mir das nicht so.
Na, wir können es, wir können es, dann nennen wir es doch einfach delivery, oder? Das ist doch ok. Transit, delivery, done. Fertig.
Das ist doch, das ist doch schon ok so, das können wir einfach, das lassen wir einfach so.
Hallo Nicky30, so, das lassen wir jetzt so, komm, das ist ok.
Es ist wirklich nicht my enum, es ist, eigentlich ist es shipment, es ist status, was findet ihr schon, status oder progress?
Progress trifft es ja eigentlich auch ganz gut, oder?
Ach, Benamung von Sachen ist immer doof. Wir lassen es jetzt einfach mal so.
Also, was man kriegt ist, dann nennen wir das aber auch hier progress.
So, was haben wir sonst noch in so einer History drinne? Wir haben die einzelnen Schritte, die einzelnen Schritte sind drinne.
Die Frage ist nur, interessieren uns wirklich die einzelnen Schritte so genau? Müssen wir die uns einzeln speichern?
Oder machen wir einfach einen Timestamp brauchen wir auf jeden Fall noch?
Weil es ist so, also nur mal so, man könnte, man könnte das folgendermaßen machen.
Wir können jetzt quasi hier drinne ne Liste, ne Liste, ne Liste machen, die dann quasi, was auch immer, quasi die einzelnen Schritte enthält.
So, was wir allerdings auch machen könnten ist, wir sagen einfach, dass unser Tracker einen Error zurückgibt und quasi jeder einzelne Eintrag für sich selbst steht und halt, die zusammengenommen ergeben die History.
Das ist wahrscheinlich noch sinniger, weil wozu, wozu soll ich das noch mal rappen in irgendwas?
Dann darf ich es aber nicht History nennen, sondern irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Chipment.
Poggers.
Mach eine History mit Current Field. Ja, das könnte ich machen, weil das entspricht ja auch ziemlich genau dem, was die DHL API zurück, zurück liefert.
Ich würde sagen, zum Einstieg, wir scheißen erstmal drauf, dass das Ding verschiedene Events gibt. Wir machen die ganz billige Variante, wir rufen es von der API ab und lesen den aktuellen Status aus und wir lesen aus den Timestamp updated, dass wir wissen, wann das zuletzt aktualisiert wurde.
Da können wir nämlich schon sagen, wenn wir Progress haben auf Delivery und updated ist quasi heute, dann weiß ich, ich kann schon mal sagen, Nachricht, das Ding befindet sich in Zustellung.
Allein mit diesen zwei Sachen können wir schon relativ viel anfangen.
Lass auch mal dieses doofe Interface weg, das brauchen wir später als zum Basteln, brauchen wir das nicht. Dann nennen wir es auch gar nicht, dann nennen wir es einfach nur Chipment.
Das Ding nennen wir jetzt irgendwie Trackzor.
Nennen wir es so, es geht ja darum, das mal zu ausprobieren. Das braucht auf jeden Fall den API Key, den API Key schreiben wir jetzt mal Plain Text rein.
Wo ist mein API Key?
Da ist mein API Key.
Der DHL Tracker.
Private Const gibt es nicht.
Wir sind ja hier nicht im C Land.
Was brauchen das Ding? Wir brauchen HTTP Client, um Abfragen gegen die DHL API machen zu können, so fühle ich schon mal sicher.
Ich kann gerade echt nicht tippen.
Auf die Idee, ich wollte es eigentlich gar nicht Static machen, ich wollte es eigentlich Read-Only machen, ich weiß auch nicht warum ich Static geschrieben habe.
Private HTTP Client, irgendwie, was weiß ich, ich habe hier HTTP Client. So, dem müssen wir eh noch ein paar Optionen wahrscheinlich im Konstruktor mit geben denke ich mal.
Wir machen erst mal Sync. Public.
Ich kriege die Information zu der Sendung wieder.
Wieso ist Receive Info für die Tracking Nummer?
Okay, die Tracking Nummer ist das da oben, das heißt das einzige was wir jetzt machen müssen ist erst mal ein Get.
Get String Async und zwar von dieser Uhr.
Das ist die Base-Uhr.
Was genau, was genau meckert er hier jetzt?
Achso.
Wenn es Async ist, muss ja sowas returnen, genau.
Du bist mein 200. Discord-User, sehr nice.
Und es ist auch kein Chebat.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach mal ohne hier irgendwie das für große Match, ich ruf es einfach mal ab, ich will mal gucken, ob es überhaupt funktioniert, was wir hier machen.
Result, also ich habe irgendwie so einen Hang dazu, Variablen, Result oder Output oder Temp oder was haben wir, es gibt einen Counter oder Next oder sowas in der Richtung zu nennen.
Red, ne Red mag ich nicht, Red benutze ich kaum, das ist mir zu C-Style.
So soll es übrigens Awaiten.
Direct, genau.
Okay, Result und wir geben das jetzt einfach mal aus.
Das ist schon ein String, ne?
Okay, wenn ich das hier abrufe, ach ich weiß, das wird übrigens, was Red ist, die Abkürzung für Return.
Also nicht direkt, sondern Get Retto.
Das wird nicht funktionieren, ich kann euch sagen, das wirft jetzt wahrscheinlich eine Exception.
Wobei wir gucken mal, wirft das eine Exception?
Nö wirft keine Exception.
Meistens wirft das eine Exception, weil das Zertifikat nicht stimmt, aber DHL hat Huge Brain und hat ein gültiges Zertifikat.
Das sind krasse Dudes, oder? Einfach mal so ein gültiges Zertifikat verwenden.
Geed Games, OA, Twitch Prime, nice, danke schön, nice you.
Jetzt sagen wir hier New DHL Tracker.
So was der jetzt machen sollte ist.
Achso.
Also Alibi mäßig das Ding übergeben.
Okay, ich weiß, es läuft Zynk.
Okay, was der jetzt machen sollte ist, da sollte uns diesen ganzen Schmodder, den wir eben gekriegt haben von DHL, sollte der uns jetzt als Ausgabe liefern.
Schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert, was ich da gebastelt habe.
Warum?
Ach, weil ich meine AP-Key gar nicht angehängt habe.
Ich bin dumm, ey.
Warte mal, wie ging das nochmal? Das musste man anders machen.
Das war ein bisschen umständlich in der Bedienung.
Man musste sagen, irgendwie Client Info oder sowas.
Gleich New und dann musste man sagen, HTTP Message Handler, musste man glaube ich sagen.
Weil ich New HTTP Message Handler.
Irgendwie so und dann.
Muss man da nicht um was?
Wie ging das nicht so?
Was war das denn für Schmerzen?
War das doch irgendwie anders?
Ich bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher.
Egal.
Ich gucke einfach nach.
HTTP Request Message.
Das ging irgendwie anders.
Default Request Headers Add.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das gewollt ist, dass ich da was hinzufüge.
Auch tatsächlich, okay.
Dachte der Mecker dann.
Aber wenn das Stack Overflow schreibt, dann kann es ja nicht so verkehrt sein.
Stack Overflow ist nicht mehr down.
Aber ich habe mich verwirren lassen, dass da Get steht.
Aber ich meine, das gibt mir ja eine komplette Liste und da kann ich dann auch was anhängen.
String.
Das da.
Mit dem da.
So.
Das so funktioniert.
Allerdings, wie hat man nochmal Custom Händler gesetzt?
Geht auch irgendwo.
Ignore SSL Errors, das musste man auch so machen, wenn man da.
Ja genau, das ist die alte Variante.
Web Request Händler musste man nehmen.
Web Request Händler nicht einfach.
Manchmal ist die Benahme auch echt ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig, aber man muss es einfach wissen.
Weißt du, ob man Windows Multi Desktop auch auf unterschiedliche Monitore begrenzen kann?
Keine Ahnung.
Man könnte übrigens an der Stelle einfach auch das da nehmen.
So, mal gucken, ob sie jetzt funktioniert.
Aha.
Funktioniert.
Jetzt können wir da das Jason rauspasen.
Mal was gucken.
Web Request Händler.
Können die das hinzufügen?
Install?
Warum soll ich das installieren?
Das ist schon drauf.
Okay, ich bin verwirrt, was auch immer, wir lassen es jetzt erst mal so.
So, es funktioniert.
Okay, dann können wir das jetzt hier unten natürlich richtig machen.
Hier ist unser APK drinne.
Denkst, das funktioniert mit dem abrufen.
Da machen wir jetzt sowas draus wie.
Ich glaube, das kommt man damit ganz schön zusammenfügen.
Ich meine, ich kann es auch einfach, ich kann einfach einen Plus dazwischen machen.
Das funktioniert natürlich auch, aber die schönere Variante ist wahrscheinlich sowas hier.
Was ist das Problem?
Ach so, das muss schon wohl sein.
Nee, dann ist mir das zu doof.
Dann habe ich da keinen Bock drauf.
Dann mache ich einfach so.
Fertig.
Ach, Quatsch, was mache ich da eigentlich?
Das ist vollkommen hirnloser, sinnloser Shit.
APK, total Fail.
ID.
So, okay, gucken wir mal, ob es noch funktioniert.
Ja, funktioniert noch.
Weil das jetzt halt so eine Sache ist.
Ich mache das halt ungern, weil das ist halt Text, den wir im Endeffekt aus einer E-Mail rausgepasst haben.
Ich würde da schon gerne sowas hier machen.
Kann man sowas wie Comcat oder so?
Kann das sowas?
Ja, das wäre cool, wenn es sowas gäbe.
Das ist aber nicht eingebaut.
Ja, die Idee bin ich auch schon gekommen.
Das sollte funktionieren.
Der nimmt den Scheiß nicht mit, ne?
Der nimmt bloß das hier mit, kann das sein?
Ach, wisst ihr was?
Da haben wir halt gute, alte Stringverkettung.
So, das ist fertig.
Okay, jetzt funktioniert der Kram auch.
Wieder, zack.
Jetzt kann man das Ganze parsen.
Ja, entweder lassen wir das als Objekt parsen.
Das muss ich mir nochmal angucken.
Entweder lassen wir das direkt als Objekt deserialisieren.
Dann müssen wir irgendwie gucken, dass unser Objekt diesem JSON-Output entspricht.
Was allerdings schwierig sein wird, weil jeder API JSON-Output ein bisschen anders sein wird.
Deswegen würde ich eher sagen, dass wir das einfach nur parsen und uns von Hand rausholen.
Was wir brauchen.
Das wird jetzt irgendwie sagen.
JSON, pars und dann kommt da der String rein.
Wir sollten vorher noch checken.
Wobei, ne.
Wir sollten das nicht checken.
Wir sollten hier einen Try-Accept drumherum machen.
Nämlich für den Fall der Fälle, dass der Mist abkackt.
Oder aber wir handhaben es so, wie das jeder gute Programmierer macht.
Er verlässt sich darauf, dass seine Programme fehlerfrei sind und generell keine Probleme verursacht.
Das würde ihr sagen, ist der bessere Ansatz.
So, jetzt haben wir das Ding gepasst.
Gehen wir es mal aus.
Ah, das ist auch schon schöner jetzt, ne.
Das ist doch jetzt schon besser.
Ja gut, im Zweifelsfall kackt halt mein ganzer Background-Thread ab, weil ich ne Exception habe.
Aber ich mein, YOLO.
Warum nicht?
So, jetzt haben wir den Gramm gepasst.
Jetzt müssen wir uns hier noch rausholen.
Wie sieht denn der Output aus?
Output ist Shipments.
Alter Chat, Cute Chat, kriegt euch wieder ein.
Was ist hier los? Ja, das frage ich mich auch.
Cute Chat ist nicht cute.
Cute Chat dreht ein bisschen durch.
Das ist heute nicht Cute Chat, das ist heute PP-Gadget.
Ah, PP-Gadget.
Aber das ist nichts Schlimmes, weil ich bin auf Twitch eh der Einzige, der standardmäßig Cute Chat hat.
Die anderen haben eh alle PP-Gadget und dann ist das bei mir auch mal so.
Ok, also was steckt da drin? Shipments kommt als erstes. Holen wir uns mal Shipments raus an der Stelle.
Gucken, was wir dann für ne Ausgabe kriegen.
Shipments, was ist da drunter?
Ein Array.
Ein Array mit einem Element.
Das ist natürlich toll. Perfekt.
Gut, was haben wir als nächstes?
ID.
ID ist meine Tracking-Nummer.
Das könnte man nochmal überprüfen.
Also, ups.
Was sagen wir?
Erst nochmal War, Shipments, Luster.
Wir verlassen uns jetzt einfach mal drauf, dass das da drin steht.
So, ID.
Können wir nochmal überprüfen, indem wir uns hier die ID rausholen.
Die ID sollte, ach so, die ID haben wir da oben schon.
Scheiß auf die ID brauchen wir nicht.
Wozu? Die Abrufart funktioniert dazu schon.
Steht dort auch das Gewicht drin? Ja.
Ja, ich weiß aber nicht, wie weit das stimmt. Da müssen wir jetzt den Eichler fragen, von dem die Tracking-Nummer ist.
Da steht das Gewicht drin.
Da steht 1,34 Kilogramm.
Array start at 69. Ich dachte immer Array start by 420.
Gibt es eine API für sowas? Was ist sowas? DHL. DHL hat eine, ja.
Ich muss mal den Output nochmal angucken.
Was war in Shipments jetzt drin? Nee, was war hier drin?
ID. So, dann haben wir drin.
Service.
Herkunft. Destination.
Das ist ziemlich egal.
Axel Voss at Gamescom. Ja, was Axel Voss ausgerechnet auf der Gamescom will, ist mir unverständlich.
Der hat ja bestimmt viele Freunde auf der Gamescom.
Wahrscheinlich wird er dann ausgeboot und versteht die Welt nicht mehr.
Oder aber er ist auf so einem Panel dabei, wo die normalen Plaps überhaupt keinen Zugang haben.
Wisst ihr, so ein Selbstfeier-Panel, wo dann alle sitzen und sich gegenseitig feiern und über irgendwas komplett Sinnloses diskutieren,
weil die Leute, die es betrifft, überhaupt keinen Zugang haben?
Wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich wird es ein Panel sein, wo die normalen Zuschauer gar keinen Zugang haben.
Ok, Status brauchen wir. Status ist das Interessante.
Status steht das drin, was wir brauchen. Status dürfte dann nur der aktuellste Stand vom Paket drin sein.
Genau, dann nehme ich ein Timestamp und ein Status-Code. Das ist das, was uns interessiert.
Status und Description haben wir noch. Description ist gut, das brauchen wir.
Prop String Description
Das ist immer so ein Wort, was ich prinzipiell verkehrt schreibe, aber in dem Fall stimmt es.
Dann machen wir jetzt ein Return New Shipment und zwar kriegt das Ding Description gleich Status.
Ist das denn jetzt auch Description?
Description, Status-Code
Moment, Moment. So einfach ist es an der Stelle natürlich nicht.
Das ich wer was Max Electronics freut, rett gleich New Shipment.
Dann setzen wir schon mal das, was wir setzen können, nämlich Description ist Status Description.
Description
Progress und Updated müssen wir noch parsen aus der ganzen Geschichte.
Progress ist Delivered in dem Fall. Das müssen wir gucken, ob wir das parsen können.
Also dass wir dann sowas sagen wie Enum, Try Pass und zwar den Progress Enum.
Shipment Progress Enum
Und als Value den Status-Code
Out war Progress.
Ok Leute, was hab ich falsch gemacht, aber wahrscheinlich muss ich das einmal.
Zu String muss ich machen, warum krieg ich keine Autovervollständigung?
Autovervollständigung, Denied.
Moment, was mach ich hier, was mach ich gerade? Ach, ich muss auch nicht retten, ich muss Jason nehmen.
Richtiger Kacknoob.
Oh die Musik ist vorbei.
Wo hab ich die Musik?
Da.
Der darf jetzt nochmal wupp wupp wupp machen.
Ach jetzt muss ich's casten oder was? Und da unten ist ok oder was? Na gut.
Ok Progress, gucken wir mal ob der den richtigen Brok- den Brokress erkennt.
Transit, sehr schön.
Aber das kann nicht sein, der Progress ist nicht Transit.
Und ich kann's auch nicht parsen, weil ich den Krams komplett, komplett anders genannt hab ey.
Also man merkt echt, dass ich da schon einen Tag geschafft hab heute, ich kann mich da grad null irgendwie konzentrieren, das ist totaler sinnlos.
Das kann überhaupt nicht funktionieren, kann auch nicht funktionieren, weil die Sachen in meinem Enum heißen komplett anders.
Wie sie im Return-Wert drinne stehen, total hängen geblieben waren.
Bleibt mir im Prinzip nichts anderes übrig, wie einen Switch zu machen.
Oder ein IF, wir machen ein IF. Also quasi IF, wenn, ähm, wollen wir hier machen.
Status Code, das da, so.
Wenn Status Code, ähm, was haben wir hier, äh, Delivered?
Too String.
Wenn Status Code Delivered ist, dann ist der Brokress in dem Fall, dann.
Weil da können wir doch einen Switch draus machen.
Ah, da war doch ein Switch draus, glaubt das ganz gut. Status Code, die Code, die Status Code war Case Delivered.
Da brauchen wir gar kein super interessantes Pattern-Matching oder sowas machen.
Geht das überhaupt so dann? Ah ne, denk schon.
Was haben wir sonst noch? Case.
Was haben die von DHL denn sonst noch? Transit.
Wenn das Transit ist, dann brauchen wir Brokress Transit. Okay, das würde passen.
Dann haben wir als letzten Case noch, der uns interessiert, ähm, was haben wir, Delivered, Transit.
Ja gut, wie das, ha, ja, wie da, hm.
Das ist auch Transit.
Shipment has been loaded into delivery vehicle.
Das ist auch Transit, das ist mit DHL, für DHL ist das alles Transit.
Das heißt wir müssen jetzt nicht nur gucken, was das für ein Status Code ist,
sondern wir müssen gucken, dass in, dass in Description, äh, keine Ahnung, halt noch Delivery Vehicle drin steht.
Mit wem redet Max eigentlich? Mit dem Pepega Chat red ich heute, weil heute ist ja kein Q Chat.
Sonst ist Q Chat aber.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Status und Description? Das weiß wahrscheinlich nur DHL.
Status und Description ist hier überall gleich.
Ja, Running Low on QT's Chat, so sieht's aus und das Ebaro ist auch nicht da.
Okay, das funktioniert ja so noch nicht, ähm, glaube ich zumindest, dass man das so nicht machen kann, das muss man anders schreiben.
Also ich kann jetzt, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen, ähm, und Status, da muss ich doch ein If machen.
Wobei das neue Pattern Matching wahrscheinlich ganz gut.
Und Description ist in Contains.
Ja, das funktioniert so nicht, das muss ich anders machen.
Das darf man so nicht machen, da brauchen wir, da brauchen wir die neue, brauchen wir die neue Schreibweise.
Aber da ist das, das ist, doch, das ist im If, in dem If ist das deutlich schöner zu machen.
In dem Fall, weil man müsste jetzt sowas sagen wie, keine Ahnung, Is,
neuer, neue Pattern Matching Sonntags wäre dann sowas in der Richtung.
Mal gucken, ob ich das aus dem Kopf gescheit hinkrieg.
Die neue Pattern Matching Sonntags wäre dann sowas hier in der Richtung.
War es, und, und, ne, fuck, äh, kriege ich aus dem Kopf nicht gebacken.
Go to, ja, genau.
Kann mir dieses neue Pattern Matching gedönnt einfach nicht merken.
Dabei ist die Sonntags gar nicht so, gar nicht so, gar nicht so schwierig.
Wo haben wir denn die neue?
Ach genau, man musste, when musste man hinschreiben irgendwie, ne, when.
So ging das.
Aber das Problem ist, das eignet sich nicht, weil ich will letztes Jahr hier gucken, ob da Transit drin steht.
Also ist eigentlich übelst fail.
Das geht?
Ernsthaft?
Funktioniert das so?
Hab ich ja noch nie gesehen.
Neuer Sub, der Kupfermann, Dankeschön, abonniert mit Twitch Prime.
Das funktioniert? Okay, das muss ich jetzt mal ausbilden, ob das echt funktioniert.
Hab ich so noch nie gesehen, dass das, dass das funktioniert.
In Transit, so und, ähm, dann haben wir noch den normalen Fall, wenn es, wenn es nur in Transit ist.
Ähm, Description contains Delivery, Dings, Auto.
Transit, ja.
Wir können sogar so weit gehen, dass wir sagen, da Default Fall ist, ist Transit.
Können wir uns da sparen.
So und hier ist es nämlich Status Delivery.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob das klappt.
Was, was meint er für einen Procrast? Was haben wir für einen Procrast?
Wow.
Siehste Leute?
Hätten wir doch mal unser Try Catch drumherum gemacht.
Dann. Richtig, funktioniert.
Also da sieht man schon mal unser Ansatz,
dass unser Programm so toll ist, dass es keine Fehler schmeißt, wird nicht funktionieren.
Ich muss doch einen Try Catch Block drumherum machen.
Aber nicht jetzt.
Error Handling ist eh prinzipiell komplett overrated, ja.
Wer braucht schon Error Handling? Und wer braucht Tests?
Alles komplett.
Verschwendete Zeit, in der man neue Features einbauen kann.
Und dazu kommt also erstens, wer braucht Tests?
Wer braucht Error Handling?
Und ganz wichtig, wer braucht Dokumentation?
Das sind ja drei Sachen, die sind, was man in der Zeit alles machen kann.
Ja und außerdem machen wir keine Fehler.
Das war ja auch nicht unser Fehler, das war ja der Fehler von DHL, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Und ihr wisst ja, gut lesbarer Code dokumentiert sich selber.
Hier lernt man halt noch, hier lernt man Programmieren fürs Leben.
Creed Games, so alles könnte ich machen, allerdings will ich den Krempel hier für alle möglichen Anbieter-Appis verwenden.
Und bei UPS heißt der Gram wieder komplett anders.
So müsste ich quasi für jeden Anbieter so eine extra deserialized Klasse machen.
Sowas wie DHL-Progress, UPS-Progress und dann halt so sagen, wie es da heißt.
Dann mapp ich es lieber mal kurz von Hand hier in dieser DHL-Klasse.
Mild Tracks, Dankeschön, Twitch Prime, POG.
So, jetzt haben wir das volle Programm abgespult.
Ok, jetzt haben wir alles gemacht, was wir machen müssen.
Description ist gefüllt.
Ach, Daytime, die Zeit müssen wir noch rausparserinoen.
Wie ist denn die Zeit aufgebaut?
Timestamp, das ist glaube ich ein ziemlich 0815 Standard Timestamp.
Den kriege ich, den kann ich wahrscheinlich direkt füttern.
Schauen wir mal.
Updated, updated, overrated, outdated.
Timestamp.
Daytime, pars.
Mal gucken, ob er den einfach so frisst. Schauen wir mal.
Updated, gebated.
Mal gucken, ob er den einfach so frisst.
Wenn er natürlich nah ist, dann muss ich nichts custom formatieren.
Ok, wa, info, wee.
Jaja, es ist bislang, ich meine.
Ok, schauen wir mal.
Ach so.
Vielleicht sollte ich auch noch was relevantes ausgeben.
Funktioniert. DHL verwendet ordentliche Timestamps, die man direkt parsen kann.
Ohne irgendwie Action. Guckt hier, 11.07.2019, 11.07.
11.07.2019, 11.07.
Bam.
Your face.
Das war jetzt nicht sonderlich schwer, muss ich sagen.
Also die DHL-AP ist nice.
Wir haben alle wichtigen Infos erstmal rausgekriegt, die wir jetzt unmittelbar brauchen.
Wir wissen, wo das Paket ist, wir wussten, wann das Status zuletzt geupdated wurde und wir haben den Text von DHL.
Übrigens wisst ihr, was ich vorhin gelesen habe? Bei DHL soll im Vorbeifliegen, im Überfliegen,
man kann dem Ding irgendwie eine Sprachcode mitgeben.
Dann übersetzen die das schon für dich. Das probieren wir jetzt einmal aus.
The AP request might return localized messages.
It is possible to indicate language preferred by calling user agent using language query parameter.
Das probieren wir jetzt einmal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Probieren wir erstmal mit curl aus.
Und language gleich DE, DE, DE, DEAT, GEAR, Germany.
Man weiß es nicht.
Bam, DE. Die Sendung wurde von DHL bearbeitet und wird für den Weitertransport in die Region des Empfängers vorbereitet.
Schauen wir mal russisch an.
Kann er nicht.
FR kann er aber bestimmt.
French.
Expediteur.
Communiqué. Elektronik.
Ach was.
Was haben wir noch?
AT.
Was für ein Standard.
ISO 639 1 alpha 2.
DHL, was ist mit euch los? Die verwenden ja tatsächlich irgendwelche Dinge, die es gibt.
Nordwest Kaukasisch.
ABK, AB.
Ja, das wollte ich schon immer mal wissen, wie das in Nordwest Kaukasisch klingt.
Auf Englisch, okay.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die das da sprechen.
Haben wir etwa einen neuen?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Genau, habe ich nicht gesehen. Der Chillora ist am Start. Dankeschön Twitch Prime.
Poggers.
Naisu.
Milerna auch am Start.
Wo Hiro, genau.
Hypers.
Gibt es Unternehmen, die wirklich ISO Standard sind? Anscheinend DHL.
Und warum auch nicht?
DHL ist schon von dem Stand, wir verwenden XML AP anscheinend weg.
Da bin ich ja schon mal ganz froh drum.
Okay, was haben wir noch für eine Sprache hier?
Arabisch.
Arabisch wird bestimmt unterstützt.
Arabisch ist mittlerweile auch hier in diesen Breitengraden recht verbreitet.
Auch nicht.
Afrikans.
AF.
Kannst auch nicht.
Kannst auch nicht. Okay, was kann das denn? Was kann das DHL Ding denn?
Spanisch. Was ist Spanisch? Spanisch.
ES. Das kann es bestimmt. Spanisch kann es bestimmt.
Auch nicht.
Holländisch. NL.
Ist überhaupt irgendwas?
DE und EN kann es.
Slowenisch.
SL.
Also ich muss sagen, ich bin da sehr enttäuscht. DHL.
DHL kann anscheinend, so wie es jetzt aussieht, nur Deutsch.
Deutsch und Englisch.
Das ist aber pale.
Die AP ist voll rassistischer. Anzeige direkt raus.
Also ich meine, wenn die weder Spanisch noch Französisch können. Italienisch vielleicht.
IT.
Die können ja nichts. Russisch ging auch nicht.
Russisch haben wir auch schon ausprobiert. Die können anscheinend wirklich bloß Deutsch und Englisch.
Occitanisch. Was es alles für Sprachen gibt.
Marshallesisch.
Keine Güte.
Moment. Türkisch.
Das ist in Deutschland auch wichtig. Englisch, Deutsch, Türkisch würde ich ja noch verstehen.
Auch nicht.
Ja, dann können die Dinge wahrscheinlich bloß Deutsch und Englisch.
Schwedisch.
Quatsch, müssen wir nicht ausprobieren.
Schwedisch. SV.
Also wenn die können ja sonst nichts. Nee.
Ok, Englisch und Deutsch können sie. Wisst ihr was?
Drauf geschissen. Wir verwenden die Standardsprache. Die ist Englisch.
Da können wir das nämlich auch ordentlich passen.
Weil, können wir das jetzt auf Deutsch stellen.
Dann müssen wir es doppelt abfragen. Nämlich einmal auf Englisch, wo wir wissen,
dass wenn es in Zustellung ist am gleichen Tag, dass da ein Delivery Vehicle drin steht.
Und danach müssen wir es nochmal abfragen in der Sprache auf Deutsch.
Bist du auf der.NET Cologne 2020? Ja klar, ich halte Keynote.
Ok, das war so schlecht. Davon hat sich keiner debaten lassen.
Nee, bin ich nicht.
Wenn ihr Englisch wisst, kann ihr sagen, was das ist?
Was ist was?
Ach, du meinst das Programm. Es ist um Schiffen zu tracken von deutschen Anbietern.
Wenn ihr den Trackingnummer wisst, könnt ihr eure Schiffen tracken.
Und im nächsten Stream werden wir eine Web-Interface implementieren, eine Web-Frontend,
die eure aktuellen Prognosen von euren Schiffen zeigt.
Und wir versuchen, eine Logik zu implementieren, die eure E-Mail-Account und die Trackingnummer
und automatisch die Prognosen von euren Schiffen update.
Und der letzte Schritt ist, dass ihr Notifikationen bekommen könnt.
Aber ich denke, es wird ein bisschen Zeit dauern.
Ich weiß noch nicht, wie man die meisten von diesen implementieren kann.
Heute haben wir nur geprüft, welches Schiff, welches Package-Providers,
ich weiß nicht die genaue Worte, APIs für ihre Service anbieten.
Wir haben es jetzt raus, wir wissen, dass der Kram auf dem Weg ist.
Und das letzte Update ist am 11.07. um 11 Uhr gewesen.
Das passt doch, so schön. Jetzt haben wir vielleicht noch mal einen Tri-Catch drum herum.
Wobei müssen wir da überhaupt einen Tri-Catch drum herum machen?
Na gut, das Ding wirft eine Exception, da muss ich einen Tri-Catch drum herum machen.
Wobei hatten wir uns nicht darauf geeinigt, dass unser Programm perfekt ist und nicht funktioniert?
Du suchst wahrscheinlich das Wort Shipper, okay, kann sein.
Ich habe es erst nicht gecheckt, aber das ist schon ganz schön cringe.
Okay, also wir haben hier mal einen Tri-Catch drum herum.
Tri-Catch ist im Nachhinein immer kacke einzubauen, weil dann musst du das alles in den Scope da hochschieben.
Was sagt? Ach so, Moment, was für ein Ding hat das nochmal für eine Exception geworfen?
Irgendeine HTTP-Exception oder sowas? HTTP-Request-Exception, hä?
Habt ihr zufällig im Kopf noch, was das für eine Exception war?
Ich will das nicht, ach komm, YOLO, wir fangen alle Exceptions.
Warum auch nicht?
YOLO-Coding wäre, wir lassen den Tri-Catch-Block komplett weg.
Die Sache ist eh, wenn wir den Tri-Catch-Block, eigentlich ist es total dämlich, dann einen Tri-Catch-Block drum herum zu machen,
weil, was will ich denn bitteschön returnen? Was will ich returnen hier drinnen?
Ich kann ja noch nicht mal was returnen, weil wenn das nicht abrufbar ist, dann ist es nicht abrufbar.
Also ist okay, wenn das Ding eine Exception wirft.
Ich kann da nichts returnen, ich kann den Fehler an der Stelle überhaupt nicht behandeln.
Ja, return 0 ist auch blöd. Nee, dann ist es besser, ich lasse den Exception hier einfach Exception fliegen
und dort, wo ich das dann am Ende aufrufe, dort kann ich das ja behandeln und sagen,
okay, dann mach einfach weiter mit der nächsten E-Mail.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht so clever an der Stelle, die Exception zu handeln,
weil ich kann halt nichts Sinnvolles zurückgeben.
Das Einzige, was ich zurückgeben könnte, ist entweder, ich mach hier noch sowas hier rein wie isEmpty oder sowas,
oder ich geb hier sowas, oder ein Optional-Wert zurück.
Das gibt es ja mittlerweile, gar nicht ob es die Sharp mittlerweile sind, sondern so eine Optional-Klasse gibt.
Glaubst du, das gibt es mittlerweile gar nicht.
Oder ich regier null zurück, was aber auch doof ist.
Da rechnet man nicht damit.
Ich würde eigentlich damit rechnen, wenn ich hier ein Chipment zurückkriege, dann steht da auch was Sinnvolles drin.
Also würde ich sagen, wir handeln die Exception an der Stelle gar nicht.
Wir lassen sie einfach so.
Übrigens, das da können wir oben machen.
Ich würde an der Stelle gar nicht damit rechnen, dass da null zurückkommt.
Ich glaube, es ist besser, wenn wir die Exception hier rausfliegen lassen.
Weil checken müssen wir es am Ende ja eh.
Ob ich da jetzt null zurückgebe und beim Aufruf hinschreibe, quasi if null im Endeffekt, und dann weitermache,
oder ob ich da die Exception fange, dann ist es wahrscheinlich schöner, ich fange an der Stelle die Exception, wo ich das Ding aufrufe.
Weil da kann ich sie nämlich auch behandeln.
Indem ich einfach die nächste E-Mail weitermache.
An der Stelle kann ich die Exception nicht sinnvoll behandeln.
Nee, ich glaube, das lassen wir so.
In dem Fall, wo ich aufrufe, wäre hier.
Hier müsste ich das machen. Das bleibt ja nicht hier.
Aber an der Stelle, wo ich aufrufe, müsste ich die Exception eigentlich einfangen.
Aber ich glaube, wenn man try-catch macht um einen Async, so eine Async-Geschichte,
dann wie war das, man darf nicht result verwenden?
Man muss, was musste man verwenden?
Get a waiter result oder sowas?
Dass die Exception auch unwrapped wird?
Das war so ganz merkwürdig in C-Sharp.
Weil standardmäßig ist es so, wenn in irgendeinem Async-Await-Gedöns Exceptions geworfen werden,
dann werden die nicht richtig unwrapped, also nicht richtig aufgebabbelt, wie man in Javascript sagen wird.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das richtig macht.
Können wir mal ausprobieren, wenn ich das jetzt hier reinschreibe.
Wir tun einfach mal so als Mega-Lull.
Wir machen einfach nix.
Wobei, das geht ja nicht, das ist ja da nicht Async.
Nee, das klappt, das muss in einem Async-Code drin sein.
Aber was auch immer, ich bin zu müde heute das ordentlich weiterzumachen.
Zumindest, wir haben heute schon mal ganz gut Progress gemacht.
Wir haben uns angeguckt, wie das DHL eine API hat, UPS eine API hat,
DPD eine API hat, Amazologistics und Amazologistics kriegen wir relativ einfach raus.
Hermos wird eklig, muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Und den Fallback für quasi so eine externe Tracking-Seite, da müssen wir den in ihre Webseite parsen.
Und das machen wir mit einem ferngesteuerten Chrome.
Da hab ich keinen Bock, das von Hand zu machen.
Da kommt ne Aggregate-Exception raus, genau, genau, genau.
Und wenn du das ordentlich erwartest, dann unwrappt er das, was in der Aggregate-Exception ist drinne.
Ich kann ja nochmal ausprobieren, ob das...
Wir können mal die Exception uns anzeigen lassen, was die Exception, was das ist.
Ne Aggregate-Exception, genau, das ist dumm.
Weil ich glaube...
Da muss man irgendwie so machen, dass man es dann rauskriegt oder so.
Ja, das ist nicht so schön.
So, und wie muss man sagen, get...
War das so, wurden dann die Results unwrapped oder musste man das wirklich evaden?
Ja, genau, den Sinn versteh ich nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung, warum das so ist.
Das ist ganz merkwürdig in C-Shrab bzw. in.NET.
Wenn du das Naheliegendste machst hier, Result, dann kriegst du nicht die Exception, die da drinne geworfen wird.
Da kriegst du so ne nichtsagende Aggregate-Exception.
Wenn du in dem Fall allerdings sagst, get a waiter, get Result,
weil Microsoft, keine Ahnung, dann unwrappt er die Exception und du kriegst sie auch zu sehen.
Warum auch immer.
Man weiß es nicht.
Der eine du weißt schon fragt, warum hast du dich für C-Shrab entschieden?
Ist das hierfür das Beste?
Ja, das Beste ist relativ. Das Beste ist immer das, wo man die Sachen am schnellsten drin machen kann oder wo man am meisten Spaß drin hat.
Kenne mich da auch mit den Unterschieden nicht so ganz aus, warum man jetzt die Sprache eine andere benutzen sollte.
Also, die Wahl der Programmiersprache ist natürlich ganz entscheidend davon abhängig, was das Ökosystem sonst noch hergibt.
Programmiersprache ist immer nur das eine. Was es da so für Libraries oder die Standard-Libraries gibt, ist das andere.
Und man muss natürlich gucken, für was für einen Anwendungszweck das Ganze ist.
Also wenn ich beispielsweise eine Windows-Desktop-Anwendung bauen will, dann würde ich das jetzt nicht gerade in Rust machen, sondern da würde ich es in C-Shrab machen.
Wenn ich beispielsweise irgendwas haben will, was ein einzelnes File gibt, was ich quasi auf eine x-beliebige Linux-Büchse kopieren kann und starten kann,
dann würde ich das Ganze vielleicht in Go machen. Oder aber in Rust, da geht das mittlerweile auch ganz gut.
Wenn ich irgendwas mal ausprobieren will, was in einem Bash-Skript zu kompliziert ist, dann mache ich das in Ruby oder manche würden das in Python machen.
Das hängt immer ein bisschen vom Anwendungszweck ab, was man nimmt.
DPD hat ja manchmal auch GPS-Tracking. Ja, da müssen wir mal gucken, ob man das rauskriegt.
Du kannst auch, weil es MotionDev gerade schreibt, du kannst natürlich auch ein Node.js nehmen und mit Packer, oder wie hieß das? Packer?
Nicht Alpacker. Packer heißt das für Node, glaube ich. Da kannst du dann dein komplettes Programm inklusive Node einpacken und eine Exit rausbasteln.
Nicht Electron. Electron ist, wenn ich GUI-Anwendungen mache.
Ich meine, dass du quasi deine komplette Anwendung zusammenpackst, inklusive aller Libraries, inklusive Node-Runtime, wo eine Exit rauskommt,
die unter der Haube im Prinzip eigentlich nur eine ZIP ist. Ich glaube Packer ist das.
Und klar, du kannst eine Electron-Anwendung machen.
Electron-Anwendung würde ich zum Beispiel machen, wenn ich was haben möchte, was auf allen Betriebssystemen läuft,
was auf allen Betriebssystemen gleich aussieht, gleich aussehen soll.
Und, wo Electron natürlich auch cool ist, wenn du ein bisschen was mit Audio und Video machen willst,
die wenigsten, muss ich jetzt noch mal relativieren, die wenigsten machen Audio-Video-Zeug in Electron.
Die nehmen das einfach als Cross-Plattform-GUI-Framework.
Aber das Coole ist, wenn man ein bisschen Audio-Video-Zeug in Electron macht, ist, da ist halt ein Chrome.
Das ist ein Chrome in einem eigenen Fenster. Das heißt, das ist alles schon drinne.
Was meint ihr, warum Discord eine Electron-Anwendung ist, beziehungsweise eine Web-Anwendung für um Desktop als Electron-Anwendung?
Weil die Leute von Discord keinen Bock haben, Audio-Video-Zeug für Linux, Mac und Windows noch mal neu zu programmieren.
Oder, was heißt neu programmieren? Neu programmieren ist das falsche Wort für...
Allein schon auch nur die unterschiedlichen Umstände und die unterschiedlichen Hersteller-Schnittstellen unter den unterschiedlichen Betriebssystemen zu verwenden.
Die nehmen einfach Electron und sagen, mach Audio, mach Mikrofon und gut ist.
Wie heißt gleich noch mal der.NET Core Packer, den du neulich erwähnt hast? Oh, da gibt es zwei Sachen.
Mittlerweile in.NET Core 3 ist sowas mit dabei. Und was ich erwähnt habe, ist ein Ding auf Rust-Basis.
Ich kann mir mit dem Namen nicht merken. Warp. Warp ist es.
Könnten die nicht SDL für Audio benutzen? Klar. Du könntest alles Mögliche verwenden, wobei ich weiß nicht, ob SDL Audio kann.
Ich habe SDL immer nur gesehen, wenn sie irgendwelche simplen 3D-Sachen gemacht haben oder ein paar Video-Frames abgespielt haben.
Aber du musst immer noch, vor allem bei Audio, auf die Besonderheiten zwischen den unterschiedlichen Betriebssystemen achten.
Und auch bei Video- und Grafik-Sachen. Das funktioniert halt nun mal unter Windows anders als unter Mac und noch mal komplett anders als unter Windows.
Unter Windows ist deine Video-Ausgabe für Videos sehr wahrscheinlich DirectX basiert, weil sonst alles CPU-gerendert wäre.
Und dein Audio ist irgendwie eine der x-beliebigen Audio-Schnittstellen, die es mittlerweile unter Windows gibt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was da... Früher war es mal Direct... Direct... Filter? Nee. Direct Show?
Es gibt immer wieder aus der Laufend was Neues.
Unter Linux wäre das so eine Mischung aus OpenGL, X-Window und PULS Audio oder ALSA. Und unter Mac habe ich keine Ahnung.
Und das willst du eigentlich nicht von Hand machen. Das willst du nicht. Wozu?
Du kannst einfach einen Chrome nehmen, da ist das schon überall eingebaut für das, was du haben willst.
Morgen wieder streamen soll? Wahrscheinlich schon, ja. Aber das ist der Packer, den ich meine für.NET Programme.
Das ist echt ganz praktisch. Der funktioniert nicht nur für.NET Programme, der funktioniert für alle möglichen Sachen.
Im Prinzip ist das super simpel, was der Typ hier programmiert hat. Also trickreich und super simpel.
Das ist im Prinzip ein ZIP-Programm in Rust, was am Anfang von dem ZIP ein kleines Stück Code hat,
was nichts anderes macht, als das ZIP zu entpacken in den versteckten Ordner und daraus zu starten.
Das sieht nur so aus, als wäre es Single Axe. Es ist in der Möglichkeit ein bisschen sophisticatedere,
ein bisschen bessere Self-Extracting Axe. ZIP, Self-Extracting ZIP ist es im Endeffekt.
Welche Sprache für Desktop-Anwendungen möchtest du empfehlen? Was gerade sehr schwer im Kommen ist
und wahrscheinlich in Zukunft auch immer mehr auf dem Desktop präsent sein wird, ist Flutter.
Also Flutter und Dart. Das ist aber Zukunftsmusik.
Aktuell mit Flutter richtig gut, sind bloß Mobile-Anwendungen, aber es kommt immer mehr auf dem Desktop.
Ansonsten ist es abhängig davon, für welches Betriebssystem du was machen willst.
Willst du es native machen oder willst du es im Browser laufen lassen?
Wenn du es im Browser laufen lassen willst, ist es die einfachste Variante, die auch auf allen Betriebssystemen gleich aussieht.
Dann nimmst du die Elektron. Ja, was kippt.
Wenn du es native machen willst, dann musst du gucken, für was für ein Betriebssystem.
Unter Mac würde ich wahrscheinlich Swift nehmen, unter Windows nehme ich ganz klar.NET.
Irgendeine.NET Sprache. Tja, und unter Linux ist da so ein Ding.
Unter Linux bleibt ja eigentlich nur Qt übrig, so richtig.
GTK ist nicht mal ein Fall.
Und Qt ordentlich geht nur in C++.
Oder halber nimmst du auch Elektron.
Echt? Ich dachte, dass Mobile-Anwendungen das absolute Aushängeschild von Flutter sind.
Ich finde Flutter vom Ansatz her cool.
Stimmt, Python bindings für Qt sind auch ziemlich gut. Ja, das stimmt.
Aber nur unter Linux.
Unter Windows musst du ja dann zigtausend Sachen wieder bundeln.
Dann hast du dann eine Excel, die ein Anwendungsordner größer ist als eine Elektron-Anwendung am Ende.
Wenn du Python bundeln musst, Qt bundeln musst.
Ist Dart echt so schlimm?
Eigentlich finde ich Dart vom Ansatz her ziemlich cool.
Weil ich bin der Meinung, dass ein UI-Framework
seine GUI-Elemente selbst malen sollte
mit einer der auf der jeweiligen Plattform verfügbaren, beschleunigten
Draw-APIs, also quasi Direct2D, Direct3D unter Windows.
Im Prinzip ist Direct2D ein Aufsatz da drauf.
Tja, unter Linux wird es wieder schwierig.
Also ordentliche GUI-Frameworks malen ihr GUI selber.
Es gibt ein paar Ansätze, so wie das Xamarin macht zum Beispiel,
dass es versucht, die jeweiligen native UI-Elemente,
die die jeweiligen Betriebssysteme mitbringen, zu verwenden.
Das Problem ist dann aber, dass das Ding halt überhaupt nicht konsistent aussieht.
Ich meine, es ist gewollt und ungewollt.
Es ist gewollt, dass die Anwendung überall native aussieht,
allerdings die Anwendung sieht nirgendswo einheitlich aus.
Und du bist auch festgelegt auf den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner.
Also zum Beispiel hast du einen ListView oder hast du einen Button
und der Button kann unter einem der unterstützten Betriebssysteme
keine Schrift mit Großbuchstaben darstellen.
Dann kann dein Button in deinem UI-Framework erst einmal keine Schrift mit Großbuchstaben darstellen.
Wenn du sagst, ich will native GUI-Elemente verwenden
und da so einen Rapper drumherum bauen, der oben drüber eine einheitliche API bietet.
Ja, du kannst es dann wieder kompliziert machen, aber deswegen bin ich der Meinung,
ein ordentliches UI-Framework malt seine GUI-Elemente selber.
Ja, JavaFX ist okay, gibt es auch noch.
ImageUI ist auch eine Variante, das ist aber eher was für Gaming-Overlays
oder generell für Overlays, für komplette GUI-Anwendungen eher nicht,
weil da musste alles selber drin machen.
Außerdem ist es, wie heißt das, nicht SingleState, sondern
wie heißt das?
Ich sag euch gleich, was ich meine.
Nicht Persistent heißt denn?
Mode, irgendwas mit Mode heißt das.
Intermediate Mode glaube ich, ne?
Intermediate Mode?
Da steht es doch!
Ne, Immediate Mode, Graphical User Interface, genau.
Das geht halt auch nur bis zu einer gewissen Anzahl an UI-Elementen ordentlich.
Für kleine Sachen ist das super, für Standalone Sachen ist das auch cool,
wenn das halt schon in C oder C++ gemacht ist.
Aber sag mal so, ein halbwegs komplettes, komplexes UI, sowas hier,
so ein Pausa-Oberfläche oder irgendwas mit ein bisschen mehr als drei Buttons
und eine Texte-Box, würde ich da nicht drin machen wollen.
Einfach nur so, ohne Bezug zu irgendwas, was ich gesagt hab.
Boah, ich werd müde Leute.
Morgen aufgestanden, 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden.
Nichts gefuttert den ganzen Tag.
Als ich heimgekommen bin, hab ich mir da einen Döner-Teller bestellt,
hab mir den reingehauen um 17.30 Uhr
und eigentlich bin ich schon so halb im Fresskoma gewesen,
als ich den Streben angeschmissen hab.
Und langsam wird es jetzt auch so spät, dass das Fresskoma nachlässt,
aber ich langsam müde werde.
Muss mal gucken, dass ich keine Subs und Follows und Sachen übersehen hab.
Schauen wir mal.
Nee, kann ich nicht mal sehen.
Wir haben aber ein paar neue Follows.
Wen haben wir denn hier?
Artist of Death, the Caddy, Noidsme und Krasser Boy, danke.
Ist natürlich ein toller Benutzername.
Der Krasser Boy ist am Start.
Was haben wir noch?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das genau aussprechen soll.
Ich guck mal in mein Fragenbord rein, ob ich irgendwas übersehen hab,
aber so wie ich mich kennen hab, habe ich wahrscheinlich jede Menge übersehen.
Ist Amazon doppelt im Titel Absicht?
Nö.
Kann mich nicht entscheiden, ob 1066C oder Vega 56, keine Ahnung.
Wie handhabt ihr das auf der Arbeit mit Anti-Viren-Software,
beziehungsweise was hältst du davon, ich bin ziemlich gespannt.
Da hab ich mal ein Video zugemacht.
Da hab ich mal ein Video zugemacht zu diesem Thema,
wo ich mich 20 Minuten zu diesem Thema auslasse.
Ich lass mich da jetzt nicht nochmal zu aus.
Außerdem hab ich mir vor dem Video extra Gedanken gemacht, was ich dazu erzähle.
Das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen her, dass ich keine Ahnung mehr hab,
was ich mir dafür Gedanken gemacht hab.
Ich glaub Fazit in dem Video war, dass man es sich wirklich braucht
und einfach den Windows Defender drauf lassen soll und gut ist.
Ganz ohne Virenscanner würd ich's nicht laufen lassen.
Ich würd den Windows eigener nehmen und gut ist.
Also ich seh keinen Grund eigentlich, den Windows Defender auszuschalten.
Es gibt theoretisch mehr Angriffsfläche als wenn man ihn nicht anhat.
Ich mein es ja logisch.
Jedes Programm was läuft, wird extra Angriffsfläche.
Was so tief in den System integriert ist, wie der Virenscanner,
bietet natürlich nicht unbedingt mehr Angriffsfläche,
aber wenn's Angriffsfläche bietet, dann sind die Auswirkungen größer.
Ich hab ja auch ein Video damals gemacht zu dem Thema Sicherheitslücke in Windows Defender.
Hab ich schon vergessen, wie das Ganze hieß.
Das ging auch irgendwie 25 Minuten.
Wo rausgekommen ist, dass ein JavaScript Interpreter mit Root Access in Windows Defender läuft,
der Probleme hat mit dem falschen Code.
Ach ja, und wie handhabt ihr das auf der Arbeit mit Antiviren-Software?
Wir haben eine professionelle gekaufte Enterprise Business Antiviren-Lösung,
die natürlich auch ziemlicher Crap ist wie jede Antiviren-Lösung,
aber die man einfach als Alibi betreibt, dass man sagen kann, man tut was dagegen.
Das wird man generell auf dem Büsse des Umfelds sehen,
dass da nicht unbedingt die Sachen gemacht werden, die technisch vielleicht sinnvoll wären,
oder technisch unbedingt sinnvoll sind,
sondern oftmals die Sachen genommen werden, wo man sich damit am besten rausreden kann,
sollte doch was passieren.
Unsere Antivirus beziehungsweise Security-Software,
die wir da auf den Rechnern haben, ist totaler Müll.
Ich habe mal einen Nmap ausgeführt von einem Windows-Notebook,
weil ich was gucken wollte, und dann hat es mich direkt gesperrt.
Ich habe Hacker-Tools ausgeführt. Bam.
Ich habe zwar einen Admin-Account, aber Böse-Hacksore muss gleich gesperrt werden.
Direkt, genau.
Nein, nein, wir haben nicht Avira 3. Wir haben was teures.
Gibt es nicht so viele Business-Virus-Dinger.
Dann sag es Kaspersky, ist es. Kaspersky.
Was bist du von Beruf? Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Beruf.
Gibt ein extra, wo ich erklärt habe, was ich so treibe.
Was machst du heute, Max? Eigentlich der nächste Offgehen.
Ich warte nur noch darauf, dass die Essensbestellung von manchen Leuten da ist.
Machst du das jetzt in C++? Nein.
C++. Wenn ich was in C++ mache, dann sind es eigentlich nur Arduino-Geschichten
oder Microcontroller-Geschichten.
Doch, ich mache das echt. Probieren wir es mal selbst aus.
Ja, Count-off-Git-Hub habe ich gemacht.
Wo ist der Sebaru? Frag ich mich immer noch.
Das doppelte Amazon-Titel ist nicht gewollt.
Hast du Games, die du zockst, die du dich wirklich freust?
Ich gucke immer mal auf Steam. Ab und zu sind da so die ein oder anderen kleinen Sachen dabei,
die man so 10, 15 Stunden spielen kann, aber mir fehlt tatsächlich ein Game,
was ich wirklich lange am Stück spielen kann.
Overwatch hat es ja aus meiner Sicht komplett verkackt.
Es ist ein bisschen auf dem Aufsteigen.
Dann hast du wieder jetzt mit ihrer Role-Queue was,
was meiner Meinung nach schon seit Jahren hätte eingeführt werden sollen.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich damit nochmal anfange.
Ich sehe, der Chat kennt sich untereinander.
Aber ist ja auch klar, ein Cute-Chat kennt sich untereinander.
Aber mir ist halt eindeutig Cute-Chat.
Hallo, hallo. Running low on cuties. Need backup.
Schon mal mit Kubernetes gearbeitet, ja.
Ich finde, was Kubernetes angeht, eigentlich so ein halber Noob noch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Also wie es gedacht ist, zu benutzen.
Ich weiß, wie das bedienst.
Aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich damit mich wahnsinnig gut auskenne.
Was sich aber ändern lässt, ja.
Ich kann sowas immer relativ schnell lernen, wenn es drauf ankommt.
Also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise die Idee habe,
ich möchte mal mir einen, keine Ahnung, einen 5er Raspberry Cluster,
einen 3er Raspberry Cluster Kubernetes aufbauen, weil es mir da nach ist,
dann weiß ich da in der Woche Bescheid.
Haust du morgen den Streben wieder an? Vielleicht, ja. Wahrscheinlich sogar.
Hast du schon mal den Gedanken aus dem IT-Bereich zu wechseln, was anderes zu machen?
Nicht wirklich. Also meinen Gedanken schon.
Aber ich habe für mich entschieden, dass es für meine geistige Gesundheit besser ist.
Oder ich habe mich damals entschieden, dass es für meine geistige Gesundheit besser ist,
YouTube nicht hauptberuflich zu machen.
Und generell ganzen Online-Kram nicht hauptberuflich zu machen.
Oder eigentlich bin ich gerne im IT-Bereich, ja. Das ist das, was mich interessiert.
Wo ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf habe,
ist Management-Krams, wo es darum geht, mit Leuten, also Leute zu managen.
Wenn es darum geht, irgendwelche Systeme zu managen oder irgendwelche Automatisierungsgeschichten,
das ist okay, aber irgendwelche Menschen zu managen, habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Wo ich auch überhaupt keinen Bock drauf habe, sind irgendwelche BWL-Geschichten.
Das ist für mich, das ist monka-tos, ja.
Gibt es Sachen, die du Anwendungsentwicklern...
Ist geil, dass man das mit AW-Lern abkürzt.
Sachen, die du Anwendungsentwicklern in der Ausbildung empfehlen würdest.
Was würde ich Anwendungs- oder generell was würde ich Azubi so pauschal empfehlen?
Was würde ich Anwendungsentwicklern empfehlen für die Ausbildung?
Ich denke immer ein bisschen davon ab, bei welchem Laden du bist, aber so ganz pauschal.
Das könnte man so ganz allgemein sagen.
Finde dich damit ab, dass Berufsschule crap ist, da wirst du nichts lernen.
Ja, guck, dass du dich am Ende der Ausbildung auch wirklich auskennst.
In dem Bereich, der dir Spaß macht.
Weil, wenn du dich auskennst in dem Bereich, der dir Spaß macht,
ist die Chance, dass du in dem Bereich arbeiten kannst, der dir Spaß macht, natürlich viel höher,
als wenn du quasi was anderes machst und dann keine Ahnung hast von dem Bereich,
in dem du gerne arbeiten willst.
Auch wenn das dein Betrieb vielleicht nicht macht oder nach wechseln willst oder was auch immer.
Guck, dass du nicht an Möglichkeit in dem Bereich, der dir gefällt,
schon ganz gut auskennst am Ende der Ausbildung.
Was auch immer es ist, ja, irgendeiner steht total auf Datenbankzeug.
Der andere hat vielleicht den Designer in sich entdeckt und will ein bisschen mehr in die Frontentrichtung gehen.
Wieder jemand anderes steht voll auf einmal auf Cobol, auf Hosts.
Wer auch immer.
Nein.
Soll es geben.
Manch einer hat rausgekriegt, er mag eher Microcontroller-Zeugs.
Manch einer sagt sogar, ey, Business-Java-Geschichten sind voll mein Ding.
Also, ich glaube, der beste Tipp, der man ihm geben kann, ist, dass man die Ausbildung benutzt,
rauszukriegen, was einem am besten gefällt.
Dass man dann schaut, dass man sich bis zum Ende der Ausbildung den Bereich auch ganz gut auskennt.
Da ist die Schneiderman-Diagramm, ja, genau.
So was unnütztes, äh.
Das hat der Typ übrigens selbst gesagt, der es erfunden hat, dass es unsinnig ist.
Ja, es ist die neue Happy Meal for You.
Man muss einfach gucken, was einem selbst gefällt.
Ihr habt in der Berufsschule gelernt, wie eine USB funktioniert.
Das ist ja sogar was Sinnvolles.
Es ist gar nicht so schlecht, das zu lernen in der Berufsschule.
Ja, das ist gut.
Das ist ja auch ganz gut.
Das ist auch ganz gut.
sogar was sinnvolles das ist gar nicht so schlecht das zu lernen in der
berufsschule da lernt man nichts das ist etwas halbwegs sinnvolles
ihr hättet auch ethik haben können
oder deutsch oder englisch mit so einer komischen englischlehrerin die wir
hatten wo ich keine ahnung habe was die was das eigentlich überhaupt für
unterricht gewesen sein soll oder programmieren oder lehrer selbst
programmieren kann oder betriebssysteme wo man gezeigt kriegt wie man windows xp
windows 7 und windows 2000 installiert weil betriebssysteme
wieso ist ein chrome browser in der taskleiste blau weil das ein chromium
ist das da ist chrome das da ist chromium
ja das liegt daran dass die in der berufsschule oftmals wirklich nur die
wie soll ich wie soll ich es nennen so die letzten übrig gebliebenen an
lehrern haben ja die die sonstiges wo wir untergekommen sind also an der
berufsschule fällt mir vielleicht ein gescheiter lehrer ein und gerade
ausgerechnet den hatten wir so einen komischen bvl fach das ist der da über
mein ds ladekabel gefallen ist das habe ich ja schon mal erzählt zwar der
einzig gescheite lehrer den wir hatten
da zwischendrin hat er auch er hatte sich auch ein rechner gesetzt und hat
sich in seinen world of warcraft account eingeloggt
weil das war der eins gescheite lehrer
gut in der berufsschule das stimmt in der berufsschule
hört den lehrern wirklich keiner zu aber das ist auch nicht nicht schlimm dass
den keiner zuhört weil da gibt es auch nichts gescheites also berufsschule ist
wirklich das mit das sinnloseste was es überhaupt gibt generell ist die ganze
ihk ausbildung ziemlich sinnlos die ihk ausbildung ist eigentlich nur relevant
weil die unternehmen es relevant machen weil die halt so tun als könnte man dann
was und wenn man es nicht gemacht hat kann man nichts es ist wichtig also man
muss dazu sagen was ich will damit nicht sagen dass
leute gibt die quasi vor der ausbildung oder dass die meisten leute vor der
ausbildung quasi schon alles wissen was sie wissen was das ist nicht so aber die
ihk ausbildung und die berufsschule und was das gibt trägt da nicht dazu bei dass
die leute auf einmal ahnung haben das einzige was dazu beiträgt dass die leute
ahnung haben sind ist wenn sie in einem gescheiten betrieb landen der ihnen
was beibringt
schon mal was mit zilenium gemacht nee aber ich habe in letzter zeit ein paar
sachen mit pappetier gebaut ist diesem chrome fernsteuerungs ding das ist
eigentlich sehr nice
es hat sich am ende von meiner ausbildung und wie gesagt es hat sich
kein mensch wirklich dafür interessiert ja also es hat sich keiner dafür
interessiert so dass ich da aus welcher ausbildung ich gemacht habe ich habe
eine gemacht und also nicht so richtig also egal ob ein fach informatik ist
themen ich hatte auch ich hatte auch keine ahnung elektroniker elektro
dings was auch immer sonst was sie lernen können es wäre vollkommen egal
gewesen hauptsache das steht irgendwie da it sonst war es elektronik sonst war es
in der richtung irgendwie ausbildung gut ist und wo sich überhaupt keine sau
dafür interessiert hat ist was ich für eine abschlussnote habe also sowohl die
abschlussnote für in der ihk-berufung
bündlich und schriftlich und das abschlusszeugnis von der schule das
interessiert wirklich keine sau das ist nicht übertrieben es ist es ist es ist
ja keine sau trifft es interessiert wirklich niemand absolut niemand
interessiert das die meisten leute wissen wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal dass
da überhaupt eine note drauf steht ich hatte 95 prozent in meiner abschlussprüfung
bei der präsentation ja das hat keine sau interessiert
ich hätte ich hätte auch 60 haben können es gerade so bestehen es ist kein
mensch interessiert das deine betriebszeit hat sie interessiert die
arme ein betrieb hat es auch nur interessiert weil sie sich eingeredet
haben dass das wichtig ist und als dass sie quasi eine grundlage irgendwie haben
wie sie leute übernehmen und nicht und wie sie die leute nicht übernehmen also
bei mir hat es wirklich kein menschen null die wollten das auch nicht mal
sehen
das ist normal ich habe es ja hier schon ein paar mal erzählt wie meine
abschlussprüfung gelaufen ist meine abschlussprüfung ist für die für die
leute die es noch nicht gehört haben erzähle ich jetzt noch mal schnell meine
abschlussprüfung ist folgendermaßen gelaufen am tag meine abschlussprüfung
also mündliche mündliche abschlussprüfung bei der jk ruft mich
morgens also ich hatte die um 14 uhr habe ich an dem tag musste nicht auf die
arbeit habe ausgeschlafen und da klingelt irgendwie dann um halb neun klingelt das
telefon und eigentlich wollte ich klingeln lassen aber ich bin dann
trotzdem dran gegangen und auf einmal war die frau von der ihk ran die frau von
der ihk ran und hat gesagt ich bin durchgefallen
dann habe ich gesagt wie kann das sein dass ich durchgefallen bin meine
abschlussprüfung ist doch erst um 14 uhr da habe ich da habe ich so so habe ich
so habe ich am telefon gesessen wie kann ich durchgefallen sein wenn meine
abschlussprüfung noch gar nicht gewesen ist hat sie gesagt ja sie haben ihre
abschlussdokumentation von ihrem projekt nicht eingereicht habe ich gesagt
klar habe ich das eingereicht ich habe doch von euch sogar noch eine
bestätigungsemail gekriegt dass ihr es bekommen habt und da ist der ihk server
eine halbe minute wahrscheinlich so dass er noch nicht auf die festplatte
geschrieben hat abgekackt und hat meine abschlussprüfungsdokumentation nicht
gespeichert und anstatt dass die ihk mal geguckt hätte dass sie haben ja sogar
eine bestätigungsemail geschickt dass sie es bekommen haben anstatt dass sie
mal nachgeguckt haben haben sie gesagt ach nee sie sind durchgefallen gut wie
dem auch sei ich habe mich dann ganz abenteuerliche an und weise auf die
arbeit vpn getunnelt habe die email rausgesucht habe ihr die email weiter
geleitet und da hat sie noch mal angerufen und hat gesagt ah ja gut jetzt
hat jetzt jetzt jetzt hat es erkannt und es wäre dann nicht meine schuld
finde schon mal gut dass sie das überhaupt erkennt er kennt und ich
soll einfach ganz normal zu meiner abschlussprüfung gehen und ob ich nicht
die abschluss ob ich nicht meine doko noch dreimal ausdrucken könnte und den
mitbringen also soweit zur vorbereitung und zur
professionalität der ihk da habe ich natürlich meine doko dreimal ausgedruckt
mitgebracht und die drei typen von meinem prüfungs aus meinem prüfungs
komitee da die haben quasi mein abschlussprojekt zum ersten mal gesehen
fünf minuten bevor ich angefangen habe zu präsentieren
und dementsprechend gab es auch keine fragerunde war bei mir auch so die haben
gefragt am ende haben die nur gefragt und hat es funktioniert habe ich gesagt
ja das war die fragerunde fertig 95 prozent dazu kann ich nur sagen
das war wirklich easy es facke
cool dass du daily streams jetzt noch youtube content euer was hattest du als
prüfungsthema ich habe einen vpn gebaut als prüfungsthema
ich habe einen vpn halt gemacht gebaut als prüfungsthema
allerdings habe ich natürlich das nicht ich habe ich natürlich nicht in die
prüfung geschrieben ich baue also nicht an den titel geschrieben der abschluss
der des projektes ich baue ein vpn ich habe sie ich habe was habe ich denn
geschrieben
standort koppelung
standort koppelung über eine layer 2 bridge auf basis von open vpn von auf
basis von tunnel technologie irgendwie sowas in der richtung habe ich da
geschrieben ja und im prinzip ging es darum dass ich einen vpn aufgebaut habe
einen vpn aufgebaut
das hat mich auch geil
haben in reisen 3900 x in einem gewinnspiel gewonnen kratz macht sinn den
zu verkaufen oder einen 3.700 zu kaufen, nee warum, wenn ich einen Ryzen gewonnen hätte,
du hast ja jetzt schon einen Ryzen Board, das kannst du einfach auf dein Board stöpseln
den Ryzen und ich freue ihn. Warum nicht, die ganzen alten Ryzen Mainboards, echt, ok,
dann guck mal vorher bei deinem Mainboard Hersteller, ob der das unterstützt, also
die meisten alten Ryzen 1 Boards sollten auch Dreier unterstützen, wenn das der Fall ist,
nimm einfach den Ryzen Stöpsel in deinen aktuellen Rechner rein und freu dich. Ja,
wenn es nicht, kannst du ein BIOS Update machen. 3.900 ist Stromaufnahme brutal, ja gut, für
viele Kerne und Leistung zahlt man halt auch ein bisschen Strom. Wenn du es ausprobiert
hast und festgestellt hast, du brauchst das nicht, ähm, tja, im Prinzip sind wir noch
aus dem Gewinnspiel, ja, also ich würd's nicht verkaufen. Was kriegt man da für aktuell?
Was kriegt man für den 3.900? 300 Euro? Nein, das ist ja im Endeffekt, na gut, das ist ja
nicht gebraucht, das ist ja quasi neu. 520, ja neu verpackt, ja gut, dann kann man wahrscheinlich
zumindest schon mal wenigstens 400 nehmen, 400, 450, vielleicht sogar 500, wenn das grad
knapp ist, weil ich mein ganz ehrlich, wenn ich den gebrauch, also sag mal so, wenn ich
den privat bei Ebay kaufen könnte oder neu bei nem Shop, dann würd ich den immer neu
bei nem Shop kaufen, ähm, aber wenn man ein bisschen runtergeht, ja gut, 500 Euro oder
sagen wir mal 450 Euro, kann man sich ja mal überlegen, ja. Für 450 könntest du wahrscheinlich
deinen aktuellen Rechner richtig gut upgraden. Dann vergiss, was ich gesagt hab, dann überleg
dir besser erstmal, was du mit dem Rechner genau machen willst, ob du ihn upgraden,
ob du behalten willst, upgraden willst, ob du damit was neues spielen willst und ich
mein, ich mein, für 450, 500 Euro kriegst du schon ne neue Grafikkarte und theoretisch
auch noch ne neuere CPU. Da kriegste, ja, da kannst, also für 450 Euro kannst du ordentlich
upgraden. Könntest du dir vorstellen einen Hardware-YouTube-Channel zu betreiben? Ja,
könnt ich mir vorstellen, weil, also so ein richtig Hardcore, Hardware-Channel, wo ich
dann quasi, ah, also ich werd das nie so gut können wie der Bauer zum Beispiel, ah,
also ja, Profi-Übertakter quasi, ahm, und er deckt das auch schon ganz gut ab. Ahm,
aber was in die Richtung, hatte ich eigentlich vor, ja, aber nicht wirklich Hardware, ich
würde gerne ein bisschen mehr Technik-Gedöns machen, ja. Zum Beispiel würde ich ab und
so auch gerne mal zeigen, was ich mir wieder für neuen China-Crab bestellt hab, wie die
flashbare Steckdosenleiste. Wann gibt's Cola mit Hardware-Rat? Gab's doch schon mal vor
zwei Jahren oder so. Subscriber, stimmt, der Morris1610, Pog. Was ist es für ein Sub?
Nun, oh, ein richtig echter Stufe 1 Sub, kein Twitch Prime Sub, krasser Schiss, äh, krasser,
krasser Schiss, genau. Ja, danke für deinen Sub. Bei der Gelegenheit kann ich noch mal
eine Runde Sellout starten. Falls ihr einen Amazon Prime-Account habt, könnt ihr das kostenlos
mit Twitch verknüpfen, dann habt ihr nämlich danach einen Twitch Prime-Account, da habt
ihr so ein paar neue Icons für den Chat, da seht ihr dann einfach viel, viel geiler aus
im Chat, nachdem ihr das Ganze gemacht habt. Ihr bekommt kostenlosen Prime-Loot auf Twitch
jeden Monat und ihr könnt einmal kostenlos eine Subscription verteilen an den Streamer
eurer Wahl, das Ganze kostet euch nix und der Streamer kriegt den vollen Support, wie
er von einer normalen Subscription auch kriegen würde, ohne dass es euch was kostet. Und
der 1C3Freak1CFreak, das erste kann ich nicht so genau zuordnen, aber das zweite ist auf
jeden Fall Freak, er hat abonniert, Twitch Prime, Poggers, er hat es richtig gemacht,
Twitch Prime Sub eingelöst, Ice Freak, ah, also das Gegenteil hierzu, oder? PlaggLeopard32,
Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, nice, Pog. Ups, falsch, nicht 360 Low Scope. Ich sollte öfter
Sellout machen, ich sollte eigentlich einmal pro Stunde Sellout machen, weil das bringt
immer was. Also mit den Subs von heute, soll ich mal nachgucken, wie viele Subs ich jetzt
hab, heute Morgen hatte ich 104, ich hab jetzt Subscriber, 114, das ist richtig krasser, Pog,
Poggers ist das schon, 114, ne, Flamehaze, ich krieg ja nicht alles ab, wenn ich es komplett
abkriegen würde, würde sich das richtig lohnen, aber Twitch kriegt ja die Hälfte. Was bringen
eigentlich Bits? Das ist quasi wie eine Donation. Hast kein Twitch Prime auf deinem Memeboard,
das können wir jetzt mal ausprobieren, wie sich das anhört. Hm, Twitch irgendwie doof
an, oder? Ja, das ist gut so. Oh, das Speichern Button geht nicht. Was hab ich denn da wieder
für ein komisches Zeug programmiert? Speicher Button geht nicht. Naja, da muss ich halt
neu hinzufügen. Perfekt, funktioniert. Max Software Qualität, ja. Also für das, dass
ich das so zusammengewurstet hab, funktioniert das Ding wirklich gut. Und am besten ist natürlich
immer noch, dass wir Weeb Text-to-Speech haben. Die normale Windows Text-to-Speech verwende
ich ja gar nicht mehr. Und Track der Tracker, der Tracker Track DHL, ja.
Ja, Chillora 200 IQ reicht da nicht, das bewegt sich schon eher in Richtung 900. Der Tracker,
der Track, der macht gar nix. Das ist, ja, DHL, AP-Key von DHL und ein Request auf die
Uhr mit der Tracking-Number-ID und dann das JSON rausgepasst, das ist alles. Mehr haben
wir heute nicht geschafft, das ist wieder super produktiv gewesen für drei Stunden
und 15. Max Cy-Track-Saw. Aber das stimmt nicht so ganz. Wir haben uns ja erstmal Gedanken
gemacht, wie wir das Ganze überhaupt implementieren. Das hat ja auch nochmal ein bisschen gedauert.
Und seit einer Stunde schwätzen wir einfach nur. Die DHL-AP ist offen, ja. Kann sich registrieren,
wir haben uns eine Fake-E-Mail-Adresse gemacht. Wir heißen, äh, wie heißen wir, Wubbler-No-Scout-Master
und das hat DHL ohne Probleme als korrekt Name akzeptiert und dann haben wir uns ein AP-Key
erstellt. Was der Tracker jetzt genau macht, naja, also die Idee dahinter ist, dass du
deine E-Mails durchsuchen lassen kannst und der quasi in deinen E-Mails die Tracking-Numbers
findet von den unterschiedlichen Anbietern und dann bei den jeweiligen Anbietern nachguckt,
wie weit dein Paket ist. Und dann hast du einen Webinterface, kannst du drauf gucken
oder du kannst dir eine Benachrichtigung schicken lassen. Das ist halt relativ cool, weil es
automatisch geht. Software, wo du manuell deine Tracking-Sachen hinzufügen musst, gibt's
ja wie Sand am Meer. Aber was, was das automatisch rausfiltert aus den E-Mails, gibt's eigentlich
nur bezahlt bisher. Und der Vorteil ist natürlich, du kannst es selbst hosten, du musst nicht
irgendwie alle deine privaten E-Mails an einen Dienstleister weiterleiten, der dann
deine E-Mail-Erkennung drauf macht. Darf ich die für dein Smartphone kopieren? Du musst
die gar nicht für dein Smartphone kopieren, du kannst die einfach benutzen auf deinem
Smartphone, weil das Ding halt ja ein Webinterface. Kannst einfach mit deinem Browser draufgehen.
Mobil auf dem Smartphone laufen willst du wahrscheinlich nicht. Smart Home kopieren,
wie gesagt, du kannst die einfach für dein Smart Home benutzen. Das Ding kriegt dann
auch, also ich hoffe, dass ich noch eine Home Assistant-Integration einbauen kann, entweder
direkt über die Home Assistant API oder eben, dass man einfach MQTT-Messages verschicken
kann, dann kannst du das nämlich easy in dein Smart Home einbauen. Das ist hin und
weg da Sache, ja. Ja, Max Electronics, sowas hab ich mir überlegt. Also ich hab mir schon
überlegt, wie ich das am besten machen könnte, mit Hardware und Sachen filmen. Ich würd's
ja einfach die Kamera schräg hinter mich stellen, sodass sie über mich geht, dass
man halt nur die Hände sieht oder von oben. Eine halbwegs gescheite Kamera hab ich schon,
Licht hab ich auch schon, muss nur noch gucken, wie ich die befestig. Mit deinem Staubsauger-Roboter
die Pakete an der Tür abholen lassen. Das Lustige ist, das ist gar nicht mal so weit
weg von dem, was technisch möglich ist, ne?
Der API-Key, den haben wir live im Stream erstellt, das ist kein Geheimnis. Der API-Key kann
aber nur 250 Requests am Tag und die E-Mail-Adresse, die ich verwendet habe, um das Ding zu erstellen,
ist schon expired. Also es wird wahrscheinlich immer lang dauern, bis der Account auch nicht
funktioniert. Der Sound ist weg, ne, der Sound ist nicht weg. Das ist typischer Chat-Gebate.
Mittlerweile falle ich auch nicht mehr auf jeden Mist rein. Ah, der Sound ist nicht weg.
Ok Leute, es ist 21.30 Uhr, 22 Uhr muss ich pennen. Es gibt eine Gebatte-Version von
Hengabus, ja, gibt es. Ja, aber wir müssen es jetzt nicht übertreiben.
Da schauen wir mal, wen man hosten können.
Folge ich irgendjemand, den ich hosten will?
Naja. Hast du einen in Stream, Outro? Ja, hab ich, hab ich. Also, Outro, ich mach den
Bildschirm aus und mach Super Nintendo Musik an. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das Outro nennen
kann. Der ist immer noch an seiner Wasserkühlung dran. Da hat er gestern schon dran gesessen.
Bekommen wir das Game wieder zum Laufen, was macht der denn hier?
Hab ich dir gezeigt, wie man Linux im Client booten kann, im Browser? Ja, das ist schon
alt. Der Typ, der quasi einen C-Compiler und den Linux-Kanal damals in JavaScript irgendwie
im Browser hat laufen lassen, ist schon Jahre her.
Android-Flutter-App, den haben wir auch öfters. Der 3D-Printer, du, der ist jedes Mal am Start,
der 3D-Printer-Typ. Jedes Mal. Und keiner guckt zu, jedes Mal. Die sind, die, die sind
immer am Start. Was, richtig nice, der Dude. Hatten wir den
schon mal gehostet? Nee, hatten wir nicht. Dart, ja stimmt, ist Flutter. Flutter. Was,
Stock der Disrespect spielt Modern Warfare? Ach, Remastered. Remastered, wen interessiert
Remastered. Ich dachte, das ist irgendwie eine Beta für das neue Modern Warfare.
Den haben wir dann international. Auch die Earthquake-Typen wieder.
Der BWL-Stream ist auch immer on und den guckt keiner, ne? Der BWL-Stream ist jedes Mal on
und keine Sau guckt den armen BWL-Stream. Ich weiß, was ist da drin überhaupt, was
läuft da überhaupt? Im Verhältnis zur Konkurrenz. Allerdings,
das Wachstum ist nicht mehr vorhanden. So, beziehungsweise sehr gering. Es ist rückläufig.
Den zufolge müssen wir jetzt. Geh fad. Igitt, BWL. Grill, ein mega hübsches Grill.
Was macht die denn? Was ist das denn? Fertig ist ein Zelt. Ein Zelt kriege ich wahrscheinlich
auch noch in Blender oder was das ist hin. Noch ein Video zum Abschluss. Oh ne. Das kommen
wir jetzt nicht anstreben. Writing joystick driver for linux bootloader. Warum? Weil es
geht vermute ich einfach mal. Das ist ein typischer Fall von weil es geht. Ich finde
es nice, aber braun tut es keiner, aber es geht. Das ist schon mal sehr nice. Den kenne
ich, der macht homo-assistant addons. Das ist aber glaube ich für die meisten Leute
nicht so spannend. Ach, keine Ahnung. Ich gehe jetzt off, Leute. Wir sehen uns morgen.
Ich kann nicht mehr mit Musik suchen. Macht es gut. Bis morgen, CU.